mes chers collègues
deux drames ont touché notre pays ce
dimanche
aux Contamines-Montjoie 6 personnes ont
perdu la vie dans une avalanche à
Marseille dans le centre-ville un
immeuble de 4 étages s'est effondré six
personnes sont décédées au moins deux
sont toujours recherchés
en notre nom à tous je souhaite adresser
mes pensées mieux aux victimes à leur
famille et à leurs proches l'Assemblée
nationale se tient à leur côté et aux
côtés des forces de secours mobilisées
dont je salue l'engagement
inconditionnel je vous invite à
respecter une minute de silence en leur
mémoire
je vous remercie
je vous indiquer que nous accueillons
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale
madame Martine Froget qui a été élu le
dimanche 2 avril 2023
député de la première circonscription de
l'Ariège toutes nos félicitations et
bienvenue à vous ma chère collègues
[Applaudissements]
alors l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement la première
d'entre elles va être posée par le
groupe les républicains Monsieur Nicolas
forestier vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres de l'Agriculture
et du Commerce extérieur à partir du 25
avril la France ne pourra plus exporter
sa production céréalière dans certains
pays très demandeurs en dehors de
l'Europe conséquence d'une décision de
l'un de cesse l'autorité de sécurité
alimentaire qui interdit l'utilisation
dans notre pays de la fausse fine un
insecticide utilisé pour traiter les
cargaisons de céréales dans les cales de
bateaux la filière céréalière cinquième
exportatrice mondiale et dans une
impasse totale l'utilisation se produit
est pourtant une obligation sanitaire
exigée dans le cahier des charges de
nombreux pays je pense à l'Algérie qui
veulent importer notre blé cette fausse
fine est un produit communément utilisé
dans l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne et encore une fois j'ai envie
de dire que la France s'auto-mutile dans
cette décision puisque nous ne pourrons
pas exporter plus de 11 millions de
tonnes de céréales dans des pays qui
sont pourtant nos clients depuis très
longtemps et ceci pour une valeur de 3
milliards 8 des millions d'euros et ceci
alors que les céréales traitées par la
fosse fine et importées en France elle
ne seront pas concernées par cette
décision d'insesses décisions d'ailleurs
qu'il y aura des conséquences assez
désastreuses dans certains pays qui ont
besoin de notre blé et qui pourraient se
trouver dans une situation d'impasse eux
aussi Monsieur le Ministre lances est
une agence de l'État comment l'ancêtre
peut-elle prendre une décision aussi
importante sans en avoir discuté avec le
gouvernement comment l'ancêtre peut-elle
le prendre une décision aussi importante
sans mesurer les conséquences de cette
décision sur la vie quotidienne de nos
entrepreneurs de nos agriculteurs et
aussi de nos ports français on peut
imaginer que on va passer par Gênes ou
par Anvers mais ce sera moins de travail
dans les ports français plus de carbone
dans l'atmosphère et un surcoût pour la
filière céréalière comment l'ancêtre
peut-elle motiver sa décision qui ignore
le droit européen en vigueur et l'autre
passe son champ de compétence qui est
réglement le terme en limitée au
territoire français en soxoyant le droit
d'éditer des normes dont le secteur de
l'exportation et sa décision va à
l'encontre des règlements européens et
notamment du règlement 304
merci mon cher collègue
alors la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
belge ministre délégué chargé du
Commerce extérieur de l'attractivité des
Français de l'étranger
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Forissier oui vous
avez raison la fausse fine est un
produit phytosanitaire qui est utilisé
principalement sur le blé et qui est
requis pour les exportations par un
certain nombre de pays que nous livrons
notamment les pays du Maghreb mais merci
certains pays d'Afrique comme la Côte
d'Ivoire ou le Sénégal et c'est
plusieurs millions de tonnes de blé qui
sont concernés la décision de l'ancêtre
évidemment interpelle le gouvernement et
ce d'autant que la fosse fine n'est pas
interdite au niveau européen le cadre
juridique au niveau européen est clair
et il est donc totalement permis de
l'utiliser notamment pour les
exportations lorsque ces pays qui a les
pays importateurs requiert son
utilisation nous allons donc faire ce
qu'il faut il y a encore des
clarifications juridiques
mais je peux vous garantir que d'ici au
25 avril les décisions seront prises
pour que les exportations puissent se
poursuivre c'est important pour nos
agriculteurs c'est important pour nos
exportations mais c'est surtout
important pour les pays importateurs
c'est une question de sécurité
alimentaire mondiale et c'est également
une question géopolitique dans le cadre
de la guerre actuelle de la Russie en
Ukraine merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Manuel
Bompard pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre dimanche à
zéro heure 46 une explosion a frappé
soudainement le 17 rue de Tivoli à
Marseille
l'immeuble s'est effondré dans la foulée
en portant ses habitants dans les
décombres à l'heure où je parle si
personne n'ont perdu la vie deux sont
encore portés disparus et plus de 200
ont dû quitter leur logement nos pensées
vont aux proches des victimes ou déloger
et à toutes les personnes frappées par
ce drame
je tiens à souligner ici le dévouement
des marins pompiers de Marseille des
sapeurs-pompiers des effectifs de la
protection civile des policiers
municipaux et nationaux et de toutes les
femmes et les hommes mobilisés sans
relâche depuis plus de 60 heures dans
des conditions de dangerosité extrême je
tiens à saluer aussi la solidarité
extraordinaire dont font preuve les
Marseillaises et les Marseillais
lourdement meurtri déjà il y a 4 ans par
la catastrophe de la rue d'Aubagne même
si les circonstances de ces deux drames
semblent bien différentes le moment est
aujourd'hui à la poursuite des
recherches et on recueillement viennent
aussi les inquiétudes pour les personnes
qui se retrouvent démunies et hors de
leur logement madame la Première
ministre qu'est-ce que le gouvernement
compte mettre en place pour aider aux
côtés de la ville de Marseille les
personnes touchées par ce terrible
évènement êtes-vous en mesure de nous
indiquer par exemple quelles aides
seront débloquées pour les familles des
victimes et pour aider au logement je
vous remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du logement
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
manuel Bompard à mon tour je veux
exprimer
mes condoléances et celle du
gouvernement aux familles des victimes
exprimées le soutien tout entier du
gouvernement aux personnes qui sont
encore comme vous l'avez rappelé des
loger vous remerciez ainsi que
l'ensemble des parlementaires d'avoir
été présents aux côtés de Gérald
Darmanin dimanche et à mes côtés hier
pour écouter
les informations de l'amiral des
marins-pompiers de Marseille et je veux
aussi bien évidemment saluer le
magnifique travail réalisé par les
marins-pompiers de Marseille depuis les
premières heures de ce terrible drame
comme vous l'avez fait comme vous l'avez
fait monsieur le député saluer aussi le
travail des forces de police municipale
et nationale qui sont elles aussi
présentes pour assurer la sécurité de ce
site bien évidemment le temps de
l'enquête a commencé le temps de
recherche des victimes continues et
comme vous l'avez pu le constater hier
le travail conjoint entre la
municipalité le maire de Marseille la
métropole et les services de l'État sont
constants constants pour être présent
aux côtés des familles des victimes être
présent aux côtés des familles qui sont
délogées vous l'avez dit 200 personnes
aujourd'hui n'ont pas encore pu
rejoindre leur domicile une cinquantaine
ont dormi à l'hôtel avec cet enfant le
travail du relogement sera notre
priorité le travail de l'accompagnement
de ces familles sera notre priorité le
gouvernement sera aux côtés des familles
jusqu'à ce que chacun ait pu regagner un
domicile ou un autre vous pouvez en être
assuré j'étais encore au téléphone ce
matin et avec le préfet avec la
Direction générale des services de la
Ville de Marseille et je continuerai à
vous informer comme les autres députés
marseillais de ce qui sera mise en place
merci merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Sabrina agressive
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche Marseille a été frappé par un
drame une catastrophe j'ai une pensée
émue pour toutes les familles des
victimes de ce terrible événement qui
s'est déroulée rue de Tivoli au cœur de
notre cité phocéenne je pense également
aux 200 personnes qui ont pu être
évacuées avec réactivité efficacité par
nos marins-pompiers avec l'ensemble de
mes collègues députés de notre ville de
Marseille nous tenons à rendre hommage
au courage et au travail des
marins-pompiers des forces de secours
des forces de l'ordre des services de
l'état de la ville de Marseille et de la
métropole notre ville est l'une des plus
anciennes villes de France elle revêt
par nature des spécificités son orbes
son urbanisme est le fruit de son
histoire le centre-ville c'est toujours
reconstruit sur lui-même il est alors
actuel caractérisé par une cohabitation
de si l'architecturaux de différentes
époques toutefois ce drame nous oblige
ils nous oblige car la crise du logement
est une immense préoccupation des
Français il nous oblige car le logement
est une clé de la cohésion de la nation
il est le déterminant des trajectoires
d'intégration ou d'exclusion la crise
polyforme à laquelle le logement est
confronté est prise à balle à bras le
corps par la stratégie du plan
marseillan du président de la République
Marseille est résiliente Marseille et
solidaire elle a toujours su faire face
elle fait face elle saura faire face au
delà des spécificités de notre ville
comme dans d'autres villes anciennes en
France le chantier du logement est
titanesque rénovation urbaine
redémarrage de la construction
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
développement de l'offre de logements
sociaux lutte contre le contre les
marchands de sommeil et lutte contre les
logements insalubre autant de défis
auxquels nous devons collectivement
faire face ma question est la suivante
comment allier les exigences des
nouveaux enjeux de la politique de la
ville avec les spécificités
urbanistiques de Marseille mais aussi
aux autres villes anciens de France de
manière plus globale quelle vision de
l'urbanisme en France pour répondre
différents enjeux qui touchent au
logement je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre la transition écologique et de
la cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
agressive
je m'associe évidemment comme chacun
nous l'avons fait en nous levant par
trois fois déjà à la fois aux victimes
aux proches et à l'ensemble des forces
de secours qui sont intervenus un titre
ou un autre ainsi qu'au service de
l'État et de la ville mais votre
question est plus large
votre question au-delà du drame elle
interroge sur le niveau de politique de
logement dans notre pays et plus
particulièrement sur la façon de
reconstruire la ville sur elle-même
d'abord parce que nous le savons quelle
que soit les logements neuves qui
pourraient se construire dans des
secteurs qui ne sont pas urbanisés nous
avons un enjeu précisément compte tenu
de la planification écologique aussi de
reconstruire la ville sur elle-même et
Marseille de ce point de vue est
emblématique elle concentre les enjeux
de mal logement les enjeux de friche les
enjeux de quartiers politiques de la
ville et de rénovation urbaine pour
faire face le gouvernement est mobilisé
autour de deux piliers d'abord sur
l'autorité du Président de la République
puisque ça faisait partie de ces
engagements de campagne et de la
première ministre et en liaison étroite
avec Dominique fort et Olivier Klein
nous avons lancé le chantier de la
décentralisation du logement et ce qu'il
faut continuer à décider depuis Paris
des zones qui sont tendues et de celles
qui ne le sont pas de celles qui peuvent
bloquer les loyers et de celles qui ne
le peuvent pas de celles qui peuvent
réglementer ce qui relève des meublés
touristiques et de celles qui ne peuvent
pas si nous ne redonnons pas davantage
de pouvoir Homer nous aurons une
difficulté du côté de la signature des
permis de construire et il y a un enjeu
crucial sur la simplification des
procédures et sur la meilleure
association de l'échelon local le
deuxième levier c'est le fond friche
1382 projets en France 750 millions
d'euros
3375 hectares de friches qui d'ici la
fin de l'année 2024 laisseront place à
95 000 logements dont un tiers de
logements sociaux 4 millions de mètres
carrés d'équipements publics près de 5
millions de mètres carrés de bâtiment
économiques en pérennisant le fond
friche dans le fond vert nous
poursuivons avec cet outil puissant qui
va nous permettre de continuer à
accompagner les territoires à se
reconstruire sur elle sur eux-mêmes
merci madame la députée merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame anapi pour le
groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
11 journée de mobilisation des millions
de Françaises et de français dans la rue
pour la première fois pour beaucoup
d'entre eux une inter syndicale au grand
complet toujours aussi déterminé et
historiquement soudés
70% de français opposés à votre réforme
est quasiment autant d'entre eux
favorables au blocage voici le bilan
catastrophique de votre gouvernement
depuis que vous avez fait le choix
d'engager quoi qu'il en coûte une
réforme des retraites aussi injuste et
injustifiée sur le fond que brutal sur
la forme
la grande sociale est historique et face
à cela un pouvoir exécutif toujours
aussi inflexible notre Constitution
permet de sortir de l'impasse
démocratique dans laquelle vous nous
avez enfermé en ayant recours d'abord au
47 ans puis au 44 3 puis au 49.3
en quelques semaines au contexte
inflationniste et à la crise énergétique
vous avez fait entrer le pays dans une
crise politique sociale et démocratique
dans les Françaises et les Français ce
serait volontiers passés votre
entêtement et l'accumulation de
contre-vérité notamment sur les 1200
euros et le nombre de bénéficiaires sont
délétères dangereux et en font chaque
jour un peu plus le pays dans la crise
dans laquelle vous l'avez installé en
lieu et place du mépris perpétuel
affiché par le Président de la
République nous avons collectivement
besoin d'apaisement madame la Première
ministre vous l'avez vous même reconnu
récemment en appelant à respecter une
période de convalescence force est de
constater que vous avez vu juste cette
réforme s'apparente à une pathologie
mais nous ne sommes pas encore en
convalescence carbone prescription c'est
le retrait
avec cette reconnaissance vous avez fait
le premier pas il ne tient qu'à vous de
faire le deuxième et de faire en sorte
que cette erreur démocratique ne
devienne pas un échec fracturant
irrémédiablement notre pacte social
madame la Première ministre allons-nous
enfin vers l'apaisement merci beaucoup
ma chère collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée pique vous avez évoqué
plusieurs sujets madame la députée mais
simplement permettez-moi de revenir sur
trois points premier point pour dire que
le texte arrive à la fin d'un
cheminement puisque vendredi le Conseil
constitutionnel aura à se prononcer à
rendre sa décision puisqu'il a été saisi
notamment par madame la Première
ministre et par un certain nombre de
parlementaires ce texte a fait l'objet
de concertation j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire maintes fois il a été constaté
pendant quatre mois il a été l'objet de
175 heures de débat dans cette hémicy
comme au Sénat il a été voté à deux
reprises par le Sénat mais aussi validé
par une commission mix paritaire composé
de représentants des deux chambres avec
la première ministre et à son invitation
nous avons reçu la semaine dernière
l'intersydicale pour dire à la fois
qu'il y a toujours un désaccord bien
évidemment sur la question de l'âge mais
dire aussi qu'il y a d'autres sujets sur
lesquels nous devrons travailler que
lorsqu'ils y seront prêts la porte de
Matignon comme celle du ministère du
travail sont évidemment des portes
ouvertes pour continuer à avancer vous
dites madame la députée que cette
réforme ne comporte une comporterait pas
d'avancer vous évoquez la pension
minimale son G5 simplement ou simplement
rappelez-vous de quelques débats avec
cette réforme un million 800 000 sur les
17 millions de retraités actuels vont
voir leur pension revaloriser ce sont un
million 800000 retraités qui vont être
valorisés dans la moitié auront une
revalorisation mensuelle de 510 à 100
euros vous considérez mesdames et
messieurs de la nuque que 70 à 100 euros
par mois c'est rien pour des retraités
qu'on 900 euros pas assez le périph
passer le périple et regarder la réalité
en face vous dites madame la députée que
cette réforme devrait être retirée la
vérité madame la députée c'est que vous
ne le ferez croire à personne j'ai été
sur vos bancs pendant longtemps en 2010
comme vous je me suis opposé à la
réforme des retraites et en 2013
qu'avons-nous fait nous avons allongé la
durée de cotisation non seulement nous
sommes parvenus mais nous avons renforcé
la réforme de 2010 je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Grégoire de
Fournas pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Marc
fenault ministre de l'Agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur le
ministre qui est absent la semaine
dernière les céréaliers se sont indignés
d'une nouvelle décision totalement
incompréhensible de l'un de cesse celle
de nos plus permettre l'usage de la
fausse fine un insecticide utilisé pour
protéger les céréales lors de leur
transport en bateau à partir du 25 avril
cette décision unilatérale conduira la
France à ne plus pouvoir exporter près
de 12 millions de tonnes de céréales
avec un préjudice de 3,8 milliards
d'euros pour par an par la balance
commerciale française comme si nous
avions encore besoin de cela cette
décision unique en Europe va fermer à
nos céréaliers des marchés essentiels
provoquant des tensions sur les prix et
le renforcement du pouvoir alimentaire
de la Russie notamment sur l'Afrique du
Nord comment une décision aussi lourde
de conséquence a pu être prise sans que
vous ni madame borne soyez intervenus
incapable de protéger nos agriculteurs
des normes absurdes d'une bureaucratie
étouffante et de distorsion de
concurrence imposée par Bruxelles qui
vous lit les mains c'est aujourd'hui
votre propre administration devenue
folle qui échappe à votre contrôle les
Français dégoûtent découvrent effarés un
gouvernement en panne qui n'a comme
programme que consultation et bavardage
et se demande monsieur le ministre quel
est ton corps votre utilité à la tête de
votre ministère j'ai entendu ce que vous
avez répondu tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre du Commerce extérieur alors que
cette décision de l'un de cesse a été
prise en octobre dernier comment
pouvez-vous vous présenter devant la
représentation nationale sans avoir
aucune réponse à nous donner alors qu'il
faut en trouver une d'ici 15 jours
monsieur le ministre on ne peut
gouverner sans assumer des choix
politiques courageux quant allez-vous
enfin reprendre le contrôle et agir pour
protéger nos agriculteurs et les
intérêts de la France
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier bêche le ministre
délégué chargé du Commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité et des Français de
l'étranger
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député de Fournas oui vous
l'avez dit effectivement la ne cesse
souhaitait interdire l'usage de la
fausse fine sur les exportations de
céréales je le rappelle il n'y a aucune
règle européenne il n'y a aucune règle
européenne qui empêche l'utilisation de
ce produit la fausse fine lorsque les
céréales sont à destination de
l'exportation lorsque le pays
importateur l'autorise lui-même
exportations sont indispensables à la
sécurité sanitaire des pays importateurs
c'est le cas notamment de l'Algérie
c'est le cas du Maroc c'est le cas du
Sénégal c'est le cas d'un Côte d'Ivoire
où les céréales françaises représentent
en ce qui concerne le bonnet parfois 65
à 95 % de ces exportations nous avons
donc besoin aujourd'hui que la phosphine
soit autoriser sur les produits
soit autoriser pour les produits à
l'exportation et c'est ce qui sera fait
d'ici au 25 avril nous cherchons le
cadre juridique clair qui permettent de
le faire il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui il y a de soucis à se faire
sur les exportations celle-ci
continueront c'est bon pour deux
exportateurs c'est bon pour la sécurité
alimentaire de ces pays c'est bon
également d'un point de vue géopolitique
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans le
contexte de la guerre d'agression de la
Russie en Ukraine pour le bien de
l'ensemble de ces pays nous continuerons
les exportations je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur de Fournas
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre les betteraviers se souviennent
de votre impuissance et de votre
incapacité à être autre chose que le
ministère du constat nous vous demandons
d'être le ministère de l'Action et vous
il vous reste 15 jours pour le prouver
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
ce gouvernement agira et nous vous le
prouverons d'ici au 25 avril
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel
Lacresse pour le groupe Renaissance
madame le Président
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre des Transports j'associe cette
question le président du lysite qui est
en président de la commission sur des
transports et qui est député de la plus
ancienne cité de France vers qui se
tourne nos regards aujourd'hui Marseille
le président de la République le 27
novembre a donné pour objectif de créer
de véritables RER métropolitain et le
rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures de notre collègue David
Valence a remis à la première ministre
une première liste cet objectif soulève
un objectif un immense attente et ma
question porte sur l'utilisation des 100
milliards qui ont précisément été
annoncés par madame la Première ministre
il faut au-delà de la poursuite des
projets de ligne nouvelle de la relance
des trains nuis des Tet créés pour les
RER métropolitains de nouvelles
infrastructures fournir de nouveaux
matériels et surtout passer aux
cadencement monsieur le ministre lorsque
vous êtes venu à Nancy tout récemment
vous avez fait état des problèmes
rencontrés à Strasbourg précisément sur
ce passage au canon mais cela ne doit
pas nous décourager et vous avez évoqué
l'idée de fournir en Lorraine un
véritable RER du Sillon Lorrain qui
irait du Luxembourg jusqu'à Nancy et
nous et nous on nous emportons la
promesse dans la prolongation de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités la question
porte sur la méthode que vous comptez
adopter le grand chantier sera-t-il mené
par l'État comme en Île de France par
des sociétés dédiées ce qui a fait le
style du Grand Paris avec SNCF réseau
comment seront associés les exécutifs
locaux à cette priorité nationale et
puis finalement quel besoin de mesures
législatives pour offrir aux voyageurs
du quotidien ou famille aux étudiants
des parcours des carbonés c'est-à-dire
complet fiable régulier et accessible
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur Clément beau nom ministre
chargé des transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
mais la crèche l'ambition des RER
métropolitains indiqué par le plan de la
République à la fin de l'année dernière
est une immense ambition pour notre pays
une immense ambition pour développer nos
transports publics pour faire face à la
transition écologique pour réduire notre
dépendance à la voiture parce que
beaucoup de nos compatriotes voudraient
pouvoir trouver des transports publics
qui les permet qui leur permettent de
faire notamment les trajets entre le
domicile et le travail mais ne peuvent
pas aujourd'hui ou pas dans des
conditions satisfaisantes c'est
l'ambition qui a décliné la première
ministre en présentant le plan d'avenir
pour les transports sur la proposition
du conseil d'orientation les
infrastructures qui en effet identifié
10 à 15 métropoles françaises qui
pourront voir ce projet se développer au
cours de la décennie qui vient si vous
me permettez de le résumer ainsi il ne
s'agit d'ailleurs ni seulement de RER ni
seulement d'un objet métropolitain quand
je dis pas seulement des RER il faudra
adapter les choses à chaque territoire à
chacune des métropoles concernées peut y
avoir des logiques de transport plus
légers voire de car Express si cela fait
diminuer l'usage de la voiture
individuel et surtout je le dis ne
s'agit pas d'un projet pour les
centres-villes seulement mais justement
pour celles et ceux qui sont à 20 30 40
km de nos centres-villes parfois plus
loin encore et qui n'ont aujourd'hui
aucune option de transport public pour
rejoindre la nôtre bout de la métropole
ou le cœur de la ville à Nancy en
particulier dans le si on l'aura un
projet mur a déjà été travaillé il fait
partie de ceux qui ont été
identifiés par les travaux menés sous la
présidence de David Valence je sais à
quel point vous y êtes attentif monsieur
le député pour cela nous devrons changer
de méthode dans les 100 milliards
d'euros qu'à annoncé la première
ministre il y aura bien sûr des crédits
pour les RER métropolitain dès la
prochaine génération de contrats de plan
état région mais nous ne devons exclure
aucune piste et les sociétés de projet
comme nous l'avons fait pour certaines
lignes à grande vitesse sont un outil
important pour cela il faudra faire
évoluer notre cadre législatif si la
représentation nationale le souhaite et
nous le souhaitons je sais que des
travaux sont déjà à l'oeuvre notamment à
l'initiative du président Voulzy et je
vous invite donc à à continuer ce
travail pour que nous puissions déployer
ses RER le plus rapidement possible
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Marie pochon pour le
groupe écologiste merci merci madame la
Présidente
cette question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture chaque
génération sans doute se voit vouée à
refaire le monde la mienne c'est
pourtant qu'elle ne le refera pas mais
sa tâche est peut-être encore plus
grande elle consiste à empêcher que le
monde ne se défasse disait Albert Camus
incendie monstre manque de fourrage
sécheresse historique ce monde qui se
défait nous le voyons chaque jour devant
nous et pourtant ces derniers mois c'est
à l'écologique que certains s'en
prennent nous militants de l'écologie
élu paysans sommes abasourdi épuisé
inquiet dans le Lot-et-Garonne dans les
Deux Sèvres partout les appels à
incendier les fermes les agressions de
journalistes les saccages de préfecture
les actions illégales et intimidantes
pleuvent toujours de la part de franges
radicalisée d'un modèle agricole dépassé
entre autres accusations des côtes
terrorisme de votre part les invectives
les coûts de pression le régime de
terreur oui de terreur règne dans votre
silence
le 12 novembre le 18 novembre un
militant de bassine non Mercier a été
roué de coup par deux hommes devant chez
lui sous les insultes décolos de merde
le 30 janvier Paul François agriculteur
victime des pesticides a été cagoulée
ficelé et menacé par trois hommes qui en
avaient je cite marre de voir sa gueule
à la télé à sainte-solines il nous
semble qu'un cas par encore été franchi
quelle est la prochaine étape
attendez-vous des morts on ne condamnant
pas en désignant via la cellule Déméter
les écologistes comme bosnies vous
affirmez qu'en France aujourd'hui il est
normal et même bienvenu d'insulter de
menacer des militants des élus et même
des fonctionnaires comme lors de
l'incendie de l'OSB à Brest comment
s'étonner dans ce climat d'impunité que
vous entretenez sciemment que beaucoup
ne croient plus au dialogue
monsieur le ministre alors que certains
menaces et agresse parfois avec la
complaisance voir la complicité de
l'État je vous le demande êtes-vous du
côté de l'agro-business de ces factieux
de ces mafieux qui détruisent nos terres
et ceux qui les travaillent ou de celui
de nos paysans de la planète de sel et
ceux qui la protègent de quel côté est
votre ministère de quel côté est notre
République je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Marie pochon
j'excuse évidemment Marc feno et je vais
avoir l'occasion de vous répondre
le sujet c'est pas d'être d'un côté
le sujet c'est d'être de ceux qui
dénonce toutes les violences et toutes
les intimidations qui préfèrent les
agressions aux décisions de justice qui
préfèrent les insultes ou les mises en
cause plutôt que le suivi des processus
démocratiques et le simple fait que vous
soyez en train de réagir pendant que je
réponds ça témoigne du caractère trouble
que vous avez par rapport à ces
questions
vous devriez
acquiescer il y a pas d'un côté des
violences qui sont légitimes et de
l'autre des violences qui sont
illégitimes en minimisant certaines et
en voulant les opposer vous légitimez
des comportements qui n'ont pas leur
place dans la République
la question de l'eau elle est cruciale
est-ce qu'on peut sur ce sujet évitez de
se faire la guerre et mesurer en face
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution que la
sobriété et que tous ceux qui prétendent
tous ceux qui prétendent hurler ou
proposer des réponses binaires se font
les complices de ceux qui ont
simplifiant aboutissent à des
comportements desservés quel que soit
l'endroit d'où il s'exerce s'il vous
plaît est-ce que là-dessus on est
capable de trouver des consensus
républicains au lieu de se jeter des
anathèmes les uns aux autres alors que
le réchauffement climatique et le
dérèglement sont une réalité qui est pas
politique mais qui est naturel cessé
d'en faire des objets de polémique
rejoignez-nous sur les solutions
regardons au cas par cas en fonction des
territoires ce que nous pouvons mettre
en oeuvre arrêter l'idéologie entrer
dans le pragmatisme et dans les
solutions c'est à ce prix là qu'on
réconciliera nos concitoyens avec
l'écologie en en faisant pas un champ de
bataille stérile
[Musique]
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
neige laine pour le groupe liote
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre la loi Rist est
entrée en vigueur lundi 3 avril dernier
et plafonne désormais les salaires des
médecins intérimaires on doit en saluer
l'objectif tout d'abord par justice pour
les praticiens hospitaliers titulaires
qui sont bien moins rémunérés et
pourtant bien plus s'investi dans
l'hôpital public mais aussi pour
empêcher la pratique d'enchères
indécente malheureusement cette mise en
place amène des fermetures de lit et de
services comme par exemple chez moi à
Remiremont pour 30 lits dont 20 dans le
service de SSR ce qu'est ce n'est qu'un
exemple parmi tant d'autres et je pense
que sur ces bancs tous nos collègues
sont concernés
ça entraîne un problème aussi pour les
usagers mais aussi pour l'organisation
interne à l'hôpital avec des infirmières
des aides-soignantes et des ash qui se
retrouvent de faite affectés dans
d'autres services et donc avec des
conditions de travail encore plus
dégradés madame la Première ministre mes
questions seront donc très simples quel
est l'état de la situation actuelle
c'est à dire combien de médecins qui du
fait du plafonnement ce sont des engagés
de l'hôpital public et quelle mesure
envisagez-vous à court terme la
transformation d'une mérus clausus en
numérus à Perthus n'a pas
fondamentalement changé les choses nous
avons besoin de plus investir dans nos
facultés de médecine pour qu'elles
puissent former plus de futurs médecins
madame la Première ministre que
prévoyez-vous c'est une question
essentielle pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Christophe negelen
comme vous je connais les difficultés et
les craintes de nos concitoyens pour
leur accès à la santé aux soins nous
avons déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler à
plusieurs reprises et je connais votre
engagement sur ces questions avec mon
gouvernement nous sommes déterminés à
bâtir des solutions adaptées à chaque
territoire
déterminer à garantir à chacun partout
en France l'accès aux soins dont il a
besoin c'est précisément pour porter
cette volonté cette conviction que
j'étais vendredi dernier en Aveyron avec
les ministres François Brown et Agnès
Firmin le Baudot auprès des
professionnels de santé et des élus
locaux alors Monsieur Président vous
m'interrogez sur quelques points précis
d'abord sur l'intérim les nouvelles
règles ont fait l'objet de large
concertation et elles sont essentielles
pour le bon fonctionnement de notre
hôpital un très gros travail
d'anticipation a été menée par les
ministres en lien avec les agences
régionales de santé
nous suivons attentivement la situation
notamment de certaines maternités des
organisations territoriales sont mises
en place et des solutions recherchées en
lien permanents avec les élus locaux
notre objectif est clair limiter au
maximum l'impact sur les services qui
faisaient beaucoup appel à l'intérim
mais tenir aussi sur ce principe de
plafonnement pour assainir des pratiques
déloyales et décourageantes pour les
praticiens hospitaliers ensuite sur la
formation la fin du numerus clausus
était une décision attendue si elle
avait été prise plus tôt nous n'en
serions pas là le nombre d'étudiants en
médecine est en augmentation mais les
effets de cette décision vont demander
du temps donc parallèlement je souhaite
que nous travaillons à la
complémentarité entre les professions de
santé notre enjeu c'est de gagner tout
de suite du temps médical alors je ne
vais pas détailler toutes les mesures à
cet effet mais je pourrais citer par
exemple la création de poste d'assistant
médicaux d'ici fin 2024 le développement
des maisons de santé elles étaient
milles en 2017 elles sont aujourd'hui
2250 c'est plus du double et puis je
pense aussi aux nouveaux actes que
peuvent désormais accomplir les
infirmiers nous expérimentons par
exemple la délivrance de certificat de
décès ce qui était très attendu par les
mers alors bien sûr nous devons aller
plus loin construire avec les
professionnels de santé avec les élus
locaux des solutions adaptées à chaque
territoire et ce week-end comme je
l'avais annoncé un décret a été publié
qui permet aux agences régionales de
santé d'adapter les règles aux besoins
spécifiques des territoires notre
volonté est claire les règles nationales
ne doivent pas faire obstacle aux
solutions locales et puis dès cette
semaine j'engagerai des discussions avec
les associations d'élus pour faciliter
aussi l'installation des nouveaux des
jeunes soignants et notamment à porter
des réponses à leurs besoins en termes
de logement
donc monsieur le président Christophe
negelaine l'accès aux soins est une
priorité des Français alors avec les
soignants avec les élus nous sommes
déterminés à trouver des solutions
adaptées à chaque territoire je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre la parole est à Madame
Raquel Garrido pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Première ministre selon vous
la France et convalescente mais la
France n'est pas convalescente madame
car la France est malade elle est malade
de voir ses grands principes
démocratiques et sociaux foulés au pied
c'est votre loi retraite qui a donné la
fièvre à la France et sa température est
à 49-3
c'est votre 49,3 du 16 mars
qui a provoqué un mal si intense que la
mobilisation s'est vu redoublée les
Français sont malades de vous voir
parler de cheminement démocratiques
alors que depuis le début vous refusez
de justifier en droit l'usage de la
procédure prévue à l'article 47 1 de la
Constitution détournant en réalité son
usage pour organiser le passage en force
ce vendredi le Conseil constitutionnel
donnera son avis avec votre trucage vous
l'avez mis dans l'embarras s'il vous
censure il assume un rôle politique qui
n'est pas le sien s'il ne vous censure
pas il renonce à défendre la
Constitution dont il a la garde et
affaiblit alors irrémédiablement la
Cinquième République qui se porte déjà
très mal
et si vous assumiez madame votre
responsabilité est devenu l'antidote à
la maladie que vous avez vous-même
généré le pays ne s'emporterait-il pas
mieux
retirer la loi
c'est encore le message qui sera porté
en masse dans l'immobilisation ce jeudi
13 avril les décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel ne sont pas susceptibles
de recours mettez-vous là pour dire
quel que soit la décision du Conseil
constitutionnelle il n'y aura pas de
guérison sans retrait de la loi
l'aspiration démocratique est profonde
et puissante les Français tiennent de
cette constitution certains droits
fondamentaux dont celui de faire grève
et de manifester ils sont en droit de
combattre la promulgation de votre loi
retraite leur détermination est intacte
retirez la loi
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
je dois avouer que votre question me
laisse perplexe MS Perpex parce que
j'ai la grande chance de sier dans cette
hémicique depuis 2007 et depuis 2007 je
n'ai jamais jamais entendu un
parlementaire préjugé comme vous l'avez
fait d'une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel jamais
je n'ai jamais vu un parlementaire je
n'ai jamais entendu un parlementaire
remettre en cause par avance la
légitimité d'une décision la réalité
madame la députée c'est que vous
cherchez comme depuis le début du débat
sur les retraites à délégitimer les
institutions à abîmer la parole du
Parlement a abîmer l'action publique à
abîmer nos institutions et finalement à
abîmer la République par vos propos par
votre volonté de remettre en cause par
avance une décision au cas où elle vous
serait défavorable vous voulez déjà la
discréditer comme vous les discréditer
l'ensemble de la 5ème république ça
n'est pas très responsable madame ça
n'est pas très responsable et c'est
raconté des sottisans Français raconter
des sottises sur une réforme qui est
nécessaire et vous considérez comme des
campagnes nécessaires vous avez voulu
madame la députée filée l'admetaform
médical et j'ai pensé à vos pensées aux
maladies imaginaires qui disait qu'il
est parfois de ces Bossons qui ne
restent parfois au réveil de ces Bossons
que le déplaisir de les avoir cru
coucou merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe la
tombe pour le groupe démocrate merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Fonction
publique monsieur le ministre l'an
dernier dans une étude intitulée
intelligence artificielle et action
publique construire la confiance servir
la performance le Conseil d'État
encouragé vivement les pouvoirs publics
à intégrer l'IA comme un paramètre
majeur des politiques publiques
notamment dans ces versions
décisionnelles pour la mettre au service
de nos concitoyens permettant ainsi d'en
maîtriser les usages et de rassurer ce
travail excellent au demeurant incitait
les pouvoirs publics à s'approprier ce
que l'on peut considérer sans faire
preuve d'en face comme un bouleversement
technologique majeur dont il est urgent
d'anticiper les impacts depuis quelques
mois l'agent conversationnel d'openhaye
chat GPT fait le buzz dans les médias et
même dans cette assemblée pour laquelle
il a déjà écrit un abonnement débattu
lors du projet de loi sur les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et une
question orale posée au ministre de la
transition numérique la semaine dernière
dans cette émission
face à la montée en performance
extrêmement rapide de cette technologie
et au caractère inéluctable de son usage
il devient en effet urgent que l’état
régule ce nouvel outil mais aussi qu'il
s'en saisisse et qu'ils en saisissent
les opportunités concernant l'action
publique l'IA décisionnels devraient
pouvoir s'améliorer et améliorer le
temps d'instruction et la pertinence du
traitement des dossiers administratifs
les agents ainsi libérés pourraient être
affectés à l'accueil des usagers qui en
aurait besoin afin de limiter les
frustrations que pourrait provoquer un
état plateforme déshumanisé pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre nous donner les
grandes lignes de notre feuille de route
comment nous administrations
envisagent-elles de s'approprier ce
nouvel outil de permettre l'émergence du
ni à souveraine donc indépendante des
gafams et protectrice des données des
Français la CNIL la Commission nationale
de l'informatique et des libertés étant
première ligne en la matière le
gouvernement envisage-t-il de renforcer
ses progressives et ses effectifs je
vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur
Stanislas Guerini ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Philippe la tombe oui l'année 2022 a été
marquée par la percée décisive des
modèles d'intelligence artificielle avec
des grandes conséquences des grands
bouleversements en matière d'emploi
d'emploi public en matière de données
personnelles en matière de
transformation des de l'emploi pardon je
le disais ou encore en matière de
souveraineté oui vous avez raison ce
sont autant de bonnes raisons pour que
l'État s'empare de ce sujet ne le
subissent pas et réfléchissent l'impact
de cette technologie sur nos
organisations et en construisant un
cadre de régulation le premier enjeu
c'est d'abord d'identifier des cas
d'usage des cas d'usage vertueux
maîtrisés de ces technologies au sein de
nos administrations avec Jean-Noël
barreau dans les prochaines semaines
nous allons annoncer une série
d'expérimentations très concrètes qui
pourront aller de la réponse aux usagers
à la simplification des démarches
administratives en passant par la
codification normative nous n'excluons à
ce stade aucun sujet le deuxième enjeu
vous le mentionnez c'est de pouvoir
développer nos propres outils qui
correspondent à nos valeurs de
protection des données personnelles de
sécurité et de souveraineté vous avez
mentionné les tchats du piti c'est la
solution la plus connue par ses
performances spectaculaires mais ce
n'est pas la seule nous avons des
alternatives de logiciels libres
européennes françaises et nous devons
capitaliser sur ces alternatives pour
nourrir la stratégie française en
matière d'intelligence artificielle qui
est déjà bien engagée avec France 2030
je veux mentionnais enfin un troisième
enjeu qui est celui de l'accompagnement
de nos agents à l'utilisation de ces
outils là encore ne subissons pas
anticipons les transformations des
métiers les besoins en formation pour
que jamais on oppose la numérisation et
l'humanisation de nos services publics
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur José Gonzalez
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
pourrait s'adresser à monsieur le
ministre des Armées la LPM 2024 2030
nous laissait espérer une autonomie
stratégique espoir de courte durée nous
apprenons que l'entreprise second qui
équipe en robinet nos bâtiments
militaires à propulsion nucléaire va
être racheté par une société américaine
vos gouvernements n'en sont pas à leur
première trahison industrielle à
l'instant mexical Catel la liste des
fleurons nationaux sacrifiés sur l'hôtel
de l'attractivité et longue il faut
expliquer aux Français qui nous écoutent
les conséquences d'un rachat américain
car le sous-marin rend toujours besoin
de robinet deux solutions sauf alors à
nous acter la création d'une nouvelle
filière de robinetterie nationale tout
en rachetant les brevets le génie
industriel que des générations de
Français ont eux même conçu se résigner
à acheter dorénavant américain prenant
le risque de se plier à leur
réglementation agressive la norme Itard
véritable outil de guerre économique
permettant le maintien de l'hégémonie
américain en matière d'exportation
d'armement après le scandale locus vous
n'en ouvre vraiment accentuer notre
dépendance aux États-Unis rassemblement
national nous considérons que la France
doit se défendre par elle-même et pour
elle-même avec le cas échéant des
coopérations avec des partenaires
étrangers alliés mais la souveraineté de
notre défense nationale doit être à la
base de nos raisonnements
des solutions existent par ailleurs à
court terme employer le décret
Montebourg afin de bloquer ce rachat et
protéger nos emplois le brevet notre
souveraineté à long terme monsieur le
ministre il nous faudra renouer avec une
politique de défense visionnaire afin
d'éviter de nagir quand réaction du fait
accomplie Marine Le Pen a proposé en ce
sens la mise en place d'un souverain
pour protéger nos entreprises
d'éventuelles prédations étrangères
s'affirmer en tant que ministre des
Armées c'est aussi faire face au
commissaire-priseur des intérêts
nationaux à Bercy ou à Matignon monsieur
le ministre comptez-vous dès lors enfin
agir pour les intérêts de la France en
bloquant ce rachat je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole
de léguer chargée des PME du Commerce de
l'Artisanat et du Tourisme
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le député Gonzalez je ne vais
pas vous refaire une histoire que vous
connaissez celle de Ségo important
robinettiez français au cœur de
l'industrie française qui intervient
principalement dans la fabrication des
sous-marins nucléaires mais également
dans les réacteurs nucléaires
Sego est actuellement détenu par
l'entreprise canadienne vélo et la
famille Velan a communiqué récemment sur
des discussions qui sont poussées avec
un autre grand robinettier vous le savez
américain qui s'appelle Flowserve un
accord de rachat par flosserve des
activités de vélo incluant Sego pour
être avoir lieu d'ici l'été
le temps est important je veux dire par
là avec le respect que je vous dois
monsieur le député Gonzalez que rien
n'est fait
bien sûr bien sûr nous sommes
particulièrement vigilants parce que ces
Go est une entreprise stratégique et
vous l'avez mentionnée les États-Unis
ont une réglementation très offensive
qui pourrait menacer la confidentialité
des informations relatives aux
technologies développées chez Sego bien
sûr cette opération va être soumise à la
procédure de contrôle des
investissements étrangers bien sûr le
ministre de l'économie avec le ministre
des Armées et le ministre de l'Énergie
Satura sur les risques d'un tel rachat
et les suites à donner le retour à
l'industrie il y a ceux qui en parlent
il y a ceux qui le font depuis 2017 je
sais que les chiffres vous ne les aimez
pas depuis 2017 ce sont 32%
d'investissement industriels en plus
dans ce pays grâce à la politique menée
par la majorité le gouvernement oui nous
avons inversé la tendance même si ça ne
fait pas vos affaires ça ne m'a pas
échappé j'en profite pour vous rappeler
d'ailleurs que depuis le décret
Montebourg vous devriez vous référer à
ce qu'a fait Bruno Le Maire en 2022
c'est à dire augmenter le plafond
étranger en France
merci
la parole est à Madame Félicie Gérard
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre en 2022
la France a exporté près de 30
mégatonnes de céréales se plaint sans
ainsi au 7e rang mondial des
exportateurs de céréales brut la France
s'impose donc comme premier producteur
européen de céréales et premier
exportateur de blé de l'Union européenne
pourtant à partir du 25 avril la France
ne bourra plus exporter sa production
céréalière en dehors de l'Europe cette
date marquant l’interdiction de
l'utilisation de phosphine pour traiter
les cargaisions de céréales dans
lesquelles des bateaux l'encas à
l'origine de cette décision impose à
présent de ne pas appliquer le produit
au contact des céréales cependant comme
le déplore nombre d'exploitants
céréaliers ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
de molécules pour garantir les
caractères sains loyal marchand exemples
vivant des cargaisons de céréales à
destination du grand export
cette nouvelle restriction aura de
nombreuses conséquences et cela a
plusieurs niveaux en effet l’utilisation
de ce produit est obligatoire dans de
nombreux pays clients de l'Hexagone pour
pouvoir débarquer la marchandise c'est
notamment le cas de l'Afrique du Nord
qui avec l'Algérie et l'un des premiers
clients de la France au grand export en
conséquence l'export des céréales
françaises sera bloquée les autres pays
européens exportateurs pouvant continuer
d'utiliser la molécule de phosphine cela
mettra la France dans une position de
désavantage fort cela représente un
risque immédiat pour notre filière
céréalière et notre commerce extérieur
la décision de l'ancêtre porte ainsi une
atteinte grave à l'export d'une filière
stratégique pour la France ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre comment le
gouvernement compte il réagir à cette
décision afin de ne pas laisser les
céréaliers sans solution et de ne pas
faire subir à la France des contraintes
à l'export qui seraient dévastatrices je
vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Marc feno ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députés merci de votre question qui
vient prolonger celles qui ont été
posées avant mon arrivée et auquel a
répondu mon collègue Olivier bacht la
France va continuer d'exporter des
céréales à l'intention des pays tiers
elle va le faire y compris après le 25
avril pour une raison simple la première
c'est qu'elle le fait dans le cadre du
droit et du droit européen qui permet
sur ce type de démarche de déroger
à l'interdiction qui est fait d'utiliser
ce tel produit je rappelle en outre que
la France va le faire à la demande des
pays d'import puisque c'est parce que
ces pays d'importation réclament cette
molécule que nous la mettons sur les
céréales et donc on va le faire dans ce
cadre là le droit la demande des pays
d'import et va le faire aussi au nom de
la vocation exportatrice qui est celle
de notre pays vous l'avez rappelé madame
elle va le faire aussi au nom de
l'exigence qui est la nôtre de faire en
sorte que la sécurité sanitaire la
sécurité alimentaire et la souveraineté
alimentaire puisse exister en Europe et
dans le monde elle va le faire enfin
parce que l'Allemagne le fait pour
l'Algérie la Bulgarie le fait pour
l'Algérie la Roumanie l'a fait pour la
Côte d'Ivoire il n'y a aucune raison que
nous dérogions à ce que font d'autres
pays européens dans leur démarche
d'experts donc madame la députée pour
répondre à votre question et à votre
inquiétude qui peut paraître légitime la
France va bien continuer à exporter des
céréales dans le cadre réglementaire et
avec un seul souci à la vérité celui de
répondre à l'exigence des pays
d'importation qui est celle de trouver
sur le marché mondial des produits de
céréales qui leur permettent de couvrir
leurs besoins alimentaires merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marc
Tellier pour le groupe TDR
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire les prix
flambent et la situation devient
insupportable pour les Français ils sont
contraints de débourser de plus en plus
pour subvenir à leurs besoins vitaux
tels que l'énergie les carburants et
surtout la nourriture des millions de
Français ont faim et doivent faire des
sacrifices et des choix difficiles pour
simplement boucler les fins de mois ils
font les courses la calculatrice à la
main et ne s'en sortent plus 4 français
sur dix déclarent sauter un repas les
bailleurs sociaux ont constaté une
augmentation des impayés de 10%, les
pâtes deviennent du caviar et les
grandes enseignes y a postent des
antivols même les associations
caritatives ont du mal à se fournir
d'aliments
de base alors dans ce contexte comment
peut-on accepter que quelques-uns
s'enrichissent indument pendant que la
majorité de nos citoyens doivent se
serrer la ceinture le fossé économique
entre les plus riches et les
travailleurs et gigantesques
c'est une véritable injustice sociale et
économique qui entrain de se jouer sous
nos yeux nos collectivités et nos CCAS
sont en première ligne aujourd'hui il se
battent pour le droit de manger alors
qu'hier il se battait pour le droit aux
vacances à la culture et à l'éducation
monsieur le ministre la solution ne se
trouve pas dans les mains des grands
industriels et des grands distributeurs
et à leur bon vouloir les Français ne
veulent pas l'aumône ils veulent vivre
de leur travail ils veulent nicher
qualimentaire ni panier anti-inflation
quand
allez-vous avec votre gouvernement
comprendre que la solution c'est
l'augmentation générale des salaires et
des pensions
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des PME du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme
merci madame la Présidente vous
comprendrez monsieur le député Tellier
que je me permets de vous répondre au
nom de Bruno Le Maire qui est
actuellement en déplacement que ce soit
difficile pour un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes je ne vais pas le nier que
l'ordre dans lequel vous avez cité les
choses et le bon je vais pas le nier non
plus énergie avez-vous dit transport
alimentation voilà exactement dans cet
ordre les trois postes de dépenses les
plus importants des ménages c'est bien
pourquoi depuis l'été 2021 dans cet
ordre énergie carburant alimentation
nous avons mis en place le bouclier et
tarifaires 110 milliards d'euros depuis
le mois d'août 2021 ça n'est pas anodin
le bouclier tarifaire c'est entre 150 et
200 euros d'économie par mois par ménage
nous avons aussi vous le savez mise en
place l'indemnité carburant destiné au
travailleur mais aussi revaloriser
l'ensemble des mini-massociaux mais
aussi les retraites nous avons mis en
place l'aide exceptionnelle de nous
avons aussi supprimé continuer à
supprimer des impôts dont la redevance
audiovisuelle bref je veux vous dire que
nous avons agi par la loi 44 milliards
d'euros dès le projet de loi de finances
rectificative 2022 mais aussi à côté de
la loi avec le trimestre entier
inflation c'est inédit vous dites que ça
ne sert à rien c'est inédit jamais dans
l'histoire de la grande distribution
l'ensemble des distributeurs se sont
engagés sur trois mois de promotion fait
tous ensemble collectivement j'aurais
l'immense loisir de communiquer dans les
prochains jours sur les premiers bilans
de ces paniers entiers inflation et des
trimestres anti-inflation qui démontrent
que les prix commencent à stagner et en
tout cas pour certains abaisser je le
partagerai avec vous je veux aussi vous
dire que pour ce qui est de demander aux
industriels de s'engager à une nouvelle
négociation parce que les matières
premières baisse et parce que les
consommateurs doivent le ressentir ces
choses faites nous avons écrit la
semaine dernière avec Bruno Le Maire à
l'ensemble des industriels pour leur
demander d'ouvrir un nouveau des
négociations nous avons été là et nous
continuerons à l'être je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Paul Molac pour le
groupe yacht
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition écologique depuis janvier
2022 l'installation des chaudières à gaz
est interdite dans les constructions
individuelles à partir de 2025 cette
prohibition s'appliquera aussi dans
l'habitat collectif aujourd'hui le
bâtissement du gaz ne concerne que le
neuf mais quand sera-t-il demain la
filière s'inquiète des discussions au
plus haut niveau laisse à penser que les
chaudiers au gaz pour être interdite le
renouveau du renouvellement par exemple
dans les bâtiments anciens avant d'être
purement et simplement prohibé partout
cette interdiction aurait des
conséquences importantes le remplacement
d'une chaudière à gaz produite en France
ou en Allemagne se fera par des pompes à
chaleur qui coûte environ 4 fois plus
cher et dont les composants proviennent
d'Asie ce ne sera pas sans effet sur
notre déficit commercial mais surtout ce
changement va provoquer une augmentation
de la consommation d'électricité pour
remplacer l'ensemble des chaudières gaz
il faudrait produire une quantité
d'électricité et équivalente à 9 EPR
dans le contexte actuel de pénurie de
production d'électricité cela peut
susciter quelques inquiétudes de plus de
nombreux agriculteurs ont investi
investi dans la méthanisation donc la
production de gaz vert directement
injectée dans les réseaux ces gaz verres
font désormais partie intégrante de
l'économie de nos territoires il nous
permettent de décarboner la filière gaz
et de sortir de notre dépendance au gaz
russe ce n'est pas le moment de mettre
fin à cette filière ou retomber positive
la filière a donc besoin d'être rassurée
sur son avenir aussi je vous poserai
quelques questions simples avez-vous
pour but d'interdire le renouvellement
des chaudières à gaz et la prohibition
du chauffage à gaz si tel était le cas
pouvez-vous nous assurer que la
production d'électricité sera en
capacité de répondre à l'électrification
massive du secteur du chauffage et que
le casse vert ne sera pas un abandonné
purement et simplement
je vous remercie
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre délégué
chargé de la ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
palmelaque permettez-moi d'excuser Agnès
panière une haché de son absence vous le
savez l'ambition du président de la
République est claire nous devons être
le premier pardon grand pays industriel
à se libérer de sa dépendance aux
énergies fossiles et atteintes dans la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 c'est un
objectif ambitieux mais nécessaire
nécessaire pour nos concitoyens
nécessaires pour la planète pour cela
sous l'égide de la première ministre
chargée de la planification écologique
nous travaillons à décliner cette
ambition secteur par secteur pour
atteindre cette neutralité carbone
concernant le chauffage à gaz qui est
l'objet de votre question vous le savez
la réglementation
RER 2020 environnementale impose depuis
le 1er janvier une part importante
d'énergie décarbonée pour le chauffage
et la production de l'eau chaude
sanitaire pour les logements neufs
cette première échéance c'est imposée
aux maisons individuelle et c'est en
progressivement à l'habitat collectif et
dans les bâtiments tertiaires et vous
l'avez dit c'est un objectif qui est
nécessaire l'objectif qui est le nôtre
c'est de produire une énergie décarbonée
le plus égard en est possible avoir dans
nos logements du confort et avoir des
effets sur les charges de copropriété et
les charges individuelles que portent
nos concitoyens et en même temps de
diminuer l'impact carbone mais il n'y a
pas à ce jour d'objectifs d'interdiction
de la production de chauffage et d'eau
chaude sanitaire dans le logement ancien
c'est un travail que nous devons mener
collectivement avec l'ensemble des
acteurs et des fournisseurs pour être
équilibré mais en tenant bien évidemment
l'objectif de décarbonation qui est le
nôtre je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur Molac
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc
j'enregistre la réponse parce que
évidemment le gaz vert peut être utilisé
à autre chose et en particulier à la
mobilité donc à un moment donné il faut
bien regarder où on va merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Patrice Perrault pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues en tant que rapporteur
de la mission d'information de la
Commission des affaires des économiques
sur la séjour de l'eau
je tiens à nouveau à saluer les annonces
qui ont été faites par le Président de
la République dans ce cadre-là le 30
mars dernier ce plan est ambitieux
comprend des mesures pour protéger les
ressources
garantir un accès équitable et cette eau
potable et à lutter contre la pollution
et les pollution de l'eau
s'inscrivant dans la droite ligne des
problématiques que je porte
effectivement au travers cette mission
je souhaiterais monsieur le ministre
vous entendre sur l'ensemble des moyens
financiers qui vont être mobilisés dans
le cadre de ce plan sur les actions qui
sont menées dans la lutte contre la
surexploitation parfois de certaines
nappes la préservation des milieux en
termes de biodiversité et l'accès à
l'eau potable dans sa grande globalité
et notamment sur les zones rurales ou
pour nos concitoyens les plus isolés
avec bien évidemment en perspective la
qualité et l'ensemble des pollutions qui
sont aujourd'hui parfois identifiés dans
l'eau
comment vous envisagez de travailler
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
que ce soit les parlementaires les
collectivités locales l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'eau pour que nous
réussissions à relever cet enjeu qui
aujourd'hui concerne bien évidemment le
quotidien de nos concitoyens mais aussi
notre souveraineté alimentaire agricole
et la souveraineté industrielle que l'on
souhaite développer
et enfin quels sont tous les
partenariats publics et privés qui
pourraient être mises en oeuvre pour
réussir à relever ce défi merci monsieur
le ministre je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Peyrot d'abord vous avez cité le rapport
du président morenas dans le corps
rapporteur était Loïc prud'hommes je
salue les députés encore très nombreux
ici qui ont participé je pense à Pascal
Boyer je passe à Hubert villefranc je
pense à 20 sentier beau et à vous-même
puisque vous avez dans le cadre de cette
mission beaucoup travaillé le plan qui a
été présenté par le Président de la
République à Savines-le-Lac
c'est d'abord le retour d'expérience de
l'été dernier c'est la suite des
rapports de la Cour des comptes et c'est
la suite des rapports parlementaires y
compris celui de juin 2018 auquel vous
faites référence et qui était très
complet sur le sujet
cette association elle a eu lieu en
amont avec le Comité national de l'eau
et les agences de l'eau c'est sur leur
base qu'on a essayé de déterminer les
niveaux financiers les axes qui étaient
nécessaires optimiser la ressource
organiser la sobriété renforcer la
gouvernance améliorer la qualité et
faire en sorte ensuite de prévoir les
moyens
l'eau dans notre pays c'est 20 milliards
d'euros de dépenses annuelles
les différents rapports y compris les
rapports issus du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale le retour des
acteurs de terrain pointe le fait qu'il
faut entre 5 et 6 milliards d'euros par
an
supplémentaires pour lutter contre les
fuites pour proposer des systèmes
d'irrigation qui soient alternatives à
des prélèvements sauvages pour organiser
une hydraulique agricole qui permet de
résoudre la question de la sobriété à
l'hectare avec les besoins de la
transition agricole
pour faire ça nous appliquons le modèle
de ce qui existe aujourd'hui
un peu plus de 2 milliards d'euros à
disposition des agences de l'eau qui
génèrent ces 20 milliards nous avons
besoin de 5 à 6 milliards
supplémentaires nous ajoutons donc
475 millions d'euros doublement de
l'enveloppe des aquaprès gérés par la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations et un
contrôle parlementaire puisque ces
mesures seront dans le PLF vous aurez
donc l'occasion bientôt d'entrer dans le
détail et je me réjouis prochainement
des auditionné par la Commission de
Monsieur zoulesi pour répondre à vos
questions de manière plus précise
[Musique]
la parole est à madame Isabelle Périgot
pour le groupe les publics
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la santé sans bruit il se
lève chaque matin avec pour seul
boussole l'envie de prendre soin des
autres quand ils sont déçus du mépris et
de l'ignorance dont votre gouvernement
fait preuve à leur égard ils ne sont pas
les premiers à crier haut et fort leur
revendications mais cette fois-ci s'en
est trop
l'exaspération des infirmiers libéraux
est en effet longtemps restée
silencieuse pourtant la colère gronde
depuis 2019 avec l'avenant qu'il est
contraint à éviter les prises en charge
lourdes car ces dernières sont moins
bien rémunérés leur forfait résulte d'un
algorithme classant les patients en
trois niveaux du plus léger au plus
lourd le montant versé est en journalier
cette situation est un supplice pour eux
puisqu'elle entraîne une dégradation
évidente de la prise en charge des
patients la loi de financement la
sécurité sociale 2023 a été pour eux le
coup de grâce en effet l'article 102 les
oblige en cas d'irrégularité sur les
règles de tarification à être redevables
d'un indus à l'Assurance Maladie
l'amalgame qui est fait entre eux et les
fraudeurs
les blesses et va fortement les
pénaliser il perçoivent cela comme une
preuve supplémentaire d'un acharnement
vis-à-vis de leur profession aujourd'hui
il est estimé que 60 professionnels sur
100 envisageraient d'abandonner leur
métier dans les 5 ans à venir vous ne
pouvez nier l'urgence et la gravité de
la situation quant à vous répondre à
leur revendication monsieur le ministre
qui sont très simples une revalorisation
de leur nomenclature gelée depuis 2012
une compensation pérenne de
l'augmentation des prix du carburant la
prise en compte de la pénibilité de leur
profession et enfin un plan pour
reprendre en main le soin en ville alors
sauver l'hôpital oui mais le libéral
aussi je vous remercie je vous remercie
ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la députée
Isabelle Périgot notre système de santé
j'ai eu plusieurs fois l'occasion de le
dire marche bien entendu sur ces deux
jambes une lampe libérale et une jambe
hospitalière il est hors de question de
favoriser l'une par rapport à l'autre
les infirmières infirmiers libéraux sont
des éléments essentiels de la chaîne des
soins de l'accès à la santé d'un nos
territoires ce sont souvent même les
seuls dans les territoires les plus
éloignés en tout cas les seuls qui vont
au plus près des patients ses patients
âgés ces patients isolés ces patients
dépendants bien entendu l'objectif est
de reconnaître au mieux leurs
compétences et le rôle qu'ils jouent
dans cette chaîne des soins ou cette
chaîne de la santé trois leviers pour
cela le premier agir sur les compétences
de ces infirmiers et faire évoluer leurs
compétences sans même parler des
infirmiers en pratique avancées je me
réjouis que la PPL riste qui a eu des
conclusions favorables reconnaissent un
rôle clé pour les infirmiers dans le
cadre d'accès direct je pense en
particulier à la prise en charge des
plaies chroniques mais également nous
avons maintenu la reconnaissance de
cette permanence des soins la
possibilité pour les infirmiers libéraux
de participer aux gardes de nuit ça a
été fait l'été dernier en particulier
pour aller dans les EHPAD et là aussi
avec une rémunération spécifique
d'autres mesures comme par exemple
expérimentation de la réalisation des
certificats de décès par les infirmiers
que je vais lancer dans quelques jours
et qui répond à des problèmes pratiques
au niveau des territoires au-delà de
cela nous faisons évoluer bien entendu
les formations des infirmiers puisque
c'est une évolution de leurs compétences
également avant la fin de l'année
modification de leur décret de
compétence qui est un décret basé sur
une liste d'actes un peu à la Prévert et
qui sera un décret sur les missions en
leur donnant plus de liberté dans leur
réalisation sur la rémunération
rapidement le besoin de le bilan de
soins infirmiers ce fameux BSI mis en
place à 2020 a été augmenté en 2022 pour
la période 2022-2024 avec un financement
qui a doublé montant à 217 millions
d'euros nous maintenant le financement
des frais kilométriques sur le principe
étoile qui permet de rembourser plus de
frais et bien entendu je suis attentif
aux effets de l'inflation sur l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé libéraux
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur
et d'agir en fonction en faveur de leur
métier merci merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas Thierry
pour le groupe écologiste madame la
Présidente cette question s'adresse au
ministre de la Santé jour après jour des
scandales sanitaires sont révélés dans
une indifférence qui confine à la cécité
dernière révélation en date par un
rapport de lances un tiers de l'eau
potable distribué largement contaminé
par les métabolites du chlorotallonyle
pesticides interdit en France depuis
2020 alors même qu’on savait au moins
depuis 2006 par la Commission européenne
que le chloro talonyl avait la capacité
de polluer massivement notre eau potable
comment se fait-il que ce métabolite
n'est pas fait l'objet d'une
surveillance plus précoce par les
services de l'État alors même que les
risques étaient parfaitement connus les
autorités savaient depuis très longtemps
et non pourtant rien fait cette inaction
est coupable elle révèle la faillite du
suivi poste homologation pour ce
pesticide et le non respect du principe
de précaution aujourd'hui le scandale
continue suite aux révélations le
gouvernement s'est voulu rassurant
expliquant que les résidus dans l'eau du
chloro talonyl ne présentaient pas de
risque sanitaires cette légèreté confine
à l'inconscience car en réalité aucune
recherche probante sur la toxicité des
métabolites n'a été conduite il n'existe
donc aucune certitude sur les effets
sanitaires à long terme d'une exposition
répétée même à petite dose au métabolite
du chloro talonyme une étude censée nous
rassurer va être menée par le géant de
l'agrochimie si j'entends cette étude
par la méthodologie choisie ne nous
apprendra rien sur les effets à long
terme et par ailleurs comment accepter
que le pollueur en l'occurrence si
j'entends soit aussi le commanditaire de
cette étude on ne peut pas être jugé par
qui la santé publique ne doit pas être
subordonnée aux intérêts des
multinationales de la grosse chimie
monsieur le ministre de la Santé
allez-vous demander l'application du
principe de précaution et le
gouvernement auquel vous appartenez
va-t-il cesser d'autoriser des
pesticides dont on sait qu'ils aggravent
les risques de la civilisation des
toxiques dont il est impératif de sortir
monsieur le ministre allez-vous défendre
nos vies plutôt que les lobbys
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès Firmin le Bodo ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député de Thierry
l'eau est notre bien le plus précieux la
qualité de l'eau destinée à la
consommation humaine et la surveillance
de cette qualité constitue des enjeux
majeurs de santé publique à la fois au
niveau national mais aussi au niveau
européen pour cette raison sous
l'autorité du ministère de la santé et
la prévention la Direction générale de
la santé missionne régulièrement les
agences d'expertise française pour
disposer de connaissances sanitaires sur
les pesticides et leur métabolites il
est évidemment essentiel d'avoir des
données d'exposition de la population à
certains contaminants dans l'eau potable
pour évaluer les risques sanitaires et
compléter la liste des substances à
surveiller l'ancêtre a publié la semaine
dernière les principaux résultats de la
dernière campagne exploratoire 2020-2022
de mesures relatives au polluant
émergents dans l'eau potable en l'espèce
que nous dit l'ancêtre il est en
évidence une continuation des ressources
en eau
va signer la consommation humaine
utilisée en France métropolitaine par
dix fines différents métabolites dont
celui du chloro talonyl un fongicide
interdit en France depuis 2020 cette
pollution représente-t-elle un risque
sanitaire à ce stade et à date la
campagne exploratoire de lancès a mis
par évidence des concentrations
maximales de deux microgrammes par litre
la valeur sanitaire transitoire
permettant de prévenir d'un risque
sanitaire et de trois microgrammes par
litre les échantillons prélevés ne
présentent donc pas de risque sanitaires
et il faut le rappeler plusieurs
responsables de la production et de la
distribution d'eau ont déjà intégré le
chloro talonyl et ses métabolites dans
leur plan de surveillance le programme
de contrôle les ARS va progressivement
intégrer à partir de 2023 le
chlorotanoline et ces métabolites dans
le contrôle sanitaire des eaux pour
rendre des résultats fiables ces
éléments permettent de poursuivre le
travail d'amélioration de qualité des
eaux en particulier pour les zones de
captage et adaptés et différencier nos
mesures par rapport aux spé cificités
territoriales comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République lors de la
présentation du plan o le 30 mars
dernier vous le voyez c'est un sujet que
nous suivons de près et avec une grande
vigilance merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Bolot pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question à
laquelle j'associe mon collègue Bruno
Miguel s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
chargée du petit et des moyennes
entreprises l'industrie porte les
emplois d'aujourd'hui et de demain elle
est l'un des moyens de la transition
écologique elle conditionne la
souveraineté de la France elle est
créatrice de richesse à redistribuer et
à partager les crises et les chocs
économiques provoquaient ces dernières
années par la covid-19 et par la guerre
en Ukraine ont conduit à une inexorable
démonstration celle du rôle crucial de
l'industrie pour une économie et des
impasse dans lesquels peut être plongée
un pays privé d'usine vous le mesurez
toutes et tous mes chers collègues et
lorsqu'une industrie en difficulté
risque de fermer ses portes sur vos
circonscriptions au-delà de ces constats
les transitions que nous devons réussir
trouverons dans l'industrie une
précieuse alliée c'est évidemment le cas
avec les transitions énergétiques et
climatiques c'est aussi le cas avec les
enjeux de justice sociale que nous
devons adosser à la redistribution les
richesse et aux partages de la valeur
par la rémunération du travail il
convient dès lors d'amplifier
d'accélérer la dynamique de
réindustrialisation de l'enfance de la
France d'ores et déjà engagées il faut
désormais viser un projet d'industrie
bas carbone conjuguant prospérité avec
économie circulaire la France ne doit
pas se laisser distancer par les pays
d'Europe ou d'ailleurs dans le monde qui
s'engagent dans un tel virage construire
une industrie viable vivable et
équitable est un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer en oubliant aucun théorie
territoire ni aucune entreprise de la
PME au plus grandes d'entre elles madame
la ministre pourriez-vous nous préciser
comment le prochain pro des lois projet
de loi sur l'industrie verte va
permettre à la France d'être à ce
rendez-vous et pourriez-vous également
nous indiquer comment les leviers de la
simplification de la fiscalité de la
commande publique et de la formation
permettront des retombées sociales
économiques et environnementales pour
tous les Français et surtout les
territoires
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des PME du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député bolo je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser la double absence de Bruno Le
Maire et de Roland Lescure Roland
Lescure et notamment au Pays-Bas avec le
président de la République justement
pour y parler industrie en France comme
à l'international le gouvernement est à
la tâche pour soutenir notre industrie
et notamment l'implantation de projets
industriels dans notre pays vous le
savez hier la France ne produisait plus
aujourd'hui la France produit de nouveau
la taxation du capital avait conduit à
l'appauvrissement du pays la politique
qui est conduite depuis 2017 notamment
sur le plan fiscal la baisse des impôts
de production permet à la nation
française de redevenir enfin une nation
de production
industrielle qui se traduit d'ailleurs
dans les chiffres dans notre pays nous
créons plus d'emplois industriels que
nous n'en avions créé c'est précédentes
années plus de 90 000 emplois
industriels ont été recréés
environ 5 ans et le solde de création
nouvelle usines et positive ça ne sert
pas les intérêts de tout le monde
puisque certains font leur politique sur
le malheur d'un certain nombre de nos
circonscriptions mais force est de
constater que les projets industriels
reviennent dans notre pays et que les
emplois industriels se recraient on a on
doit aller plus loin c'est pourquoi
Bruno Le Maire portera avec Roland
Lescure dans les prochaines semaines à
nouveau projet de loi industrie vert qui
sera d'ailleurs présenté en Conseil des
ministres prochainement et débattus au
Parlement à l'été je ne doute pas que
vous serez force de proposition
l'objectif est simple après plus de 300
consultations notamment avec les élus du
Parlement l'objectif est de faire en
sorte qu'on arrive à un consensus et
qu'on redonne les moyens aux acteurs
économiques pour implanter des
industries vers dans notre pays en leur
facilitant la tâche en leur facilitant
la vie les technologies qui vont
s'imposer sont connues l'hydrogène les
batteries les semi-conducteurs les
panneaux photovoltaïques les pompes à
chaleur bref le dérèglement climatique
est clairement le défi de ce début de
siècle et la réindustrialisation et le
défi économique de ce début de siècle je
vous remercie madame meunier merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre des Transports les
aéroports régionaux d'aménagement du
territoire traverse aujourd'hui des
zones de turbulences certains ont signé
des obligations de services publics
comme c'est le cas de l'aéroport de
Brive en Corrèze de fait dans notre OSP
l'état c’était engagé à hauteur de 50%
de participation soit 20 millions
d'euros sur 4 ans aujourd'hui à l'issue
de la première année d'exploitation il
n'a réellement participé qu'à hauteur de
34%. car les recettes sont plafonnées
aux recettes réalisées et non aux
recettes prévisionnelles mais il faut
rajouter à cela une explosion du cou du
carburant et de la taxe carbone ce qui
oblige les compagnies à dénoncer les ESP
pour obtenir des financements
supplémentaires dans nos territoires
ruraux ces aéroports sont de véritables
outils d'attractivité économiques
touristique et d'aménagement du
territoire
[Musique]
encore répondre à ces ESP je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues la parole est à monsieur
Clément bonne ministre délégué chargé
des transports
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Frédéric meunier vous avez raison
d'insister sur la nécessité d'un certain
nombre de lignes y compris aériennes
d'aménagement du territoire je fais un
détour par le train que vous avez évoqué
car il y a effectivement une ligne
essentielle une ligne de vie qui
s'appelle Paris Orléans Limoges Toulouse
qui concerne directement votre
département votre territoire et la Ville
de Brive sur laquelle nous
réinvestissons massivement depuis
maintenant 18 mois avec un effort de
renouvellement intégral des rames qui
datent parfois de plus de 50 ans et du
réseau modernisé rénové par un
financement intégral de l'État pour un
total de plus de 2 milliards d'euros et
c'est notre priorité absolue nous
assumons dans le prolongement les États
généraux et de l'aérien qui avait piloté
la ministre les Transports de l'époque
Elisabeth borne d'avoir une stratégie
complémentaire dans laquelle dans
l'attente de ces travaux ou en
complément de certaines infirmière quand
le désenclavement ne peut pas être
assuré de manière satisfaisante nous
continuons par des subventions de l'État
parfois à subventionner donc une ligne
d'aménagement du territoire ce sont 10
lignes que mon ministère soutient chaque
année pour un total de 25 millions
d'euros par an c'est un effort important
pour ce qui concerne Brive nous avons
renouvelé en début d'année dernière au
début 2022 pour 4 ans cette ligne et ses
obligations de service public le
mécanisme que vous avez décrit fait que
l'État le premier contributeur au
déficit d'exploitation nous continuerons
et nous sommes prêts je l'ai fait pour
certaines lignes encore ces dernières
semaines à regarder comment nous pouvons
adapter un certain nombre de soutiens
pour tenir compte de l'augmentation des
coûts de l'énergie nous devons le faire
de manière responsable c'est-à-dire
partager en lien avec les collectivités
qui portent aussi ses obligations pour
que le surcoût soit lorsqu'il est
possible assumer de manière équitable
partagée répartie entre les différents
financeurs je suis prêt à regarder de
nouveau avec vous pour la ligne de Brive
ce que nous pouvons faire nous avons une
priorité réinvestir un réseau
ferroviaire réinvestir nos loying de
train et en complément pour lutter
contre le désenclavagements de manière
ciblée de manière temporaire
accompagnée des lignes d'aménagement du
territoire sur le plan aérien
la parole est à Monsieur Michel Guignot
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre le 30 mars dernier
Lindsay dans le silence médiatique a
publié son rapport sur l'immigration
légale dont les résultats viennent
confirmer les analyses et les mises en
garde depuis 50 ans d'abord du Front
national puis ensuite du rassemblement
national selon les chaises les chiffres
de l'INSEE en 50 ans l'immigration
africaine a augmenté de
515%. une personne sur dix est issue de
l'immigration africaine en 50 ans
l'immigration asiatique a augmenté de
1166%. la majeure partie de cette
population immigrée ne vient pas de pays
en guerre en 2011 un résident sur 10 est
un immigré en France sans compter bien
sûr les clandestins où sont
l'immigration l'intégration et
l'assimilation certains diront que la
France a toujours été une terre d'asile
mais dans quelle proportion la France
n'a jamais été confrontée à une telle
situation en 1911 une personne sur 36
était
était immigrés aujourd'hui c'est une
personne sur dix la population immigrée
était multipliée par 6 tandis que la
population totale n'a même pas doublé
tout cela ce sont les chiffres du
rapport de l'INSEE l'exemple de l'île de
France est révélateur près d'une
personne sur 5 est immigrée 20% à Paris
21 dans le Val-d'Oise 22 dans le
Val-de-Marne 31% Seine-Saint-Denis cette
immigration déborde aujourd'hui sur les
départements limitrophes et en
particulier sur l'Oise cette immigration
a des conséquences sociales et
économiques 30% des immigrés selon
l'Insee sont sans activité 50% des
titres de séjour délivrés concernent une
immigration économique et familiale
chaque année entre 150000 et 200 000
nouveaux individus migrent légalement en
France soit l'équivalent d'une ville
comme Rennes
50% des étrangers continuent de
pratiquer leur langue d'origine avec
leurs familles leurs collègues merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Sonia baquet
secrétaire des tâches chargé de la
citoyenneté merci même la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés et
Monsieur le Député Guignot permettez-moi
d'abord d'excuser Gérald Darmanin qui
est actuellement occupé à recevoir les
acteurs les acteurs du dossier de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie la France fait
effectivement par aujourd'hui fait
effectivement face aujourd'hui à des
flux migratoires presque au niveau de ce
que nous avons connu pendant la crise de
regardez cette réalité en face avec
objectivité et mesure monsieur le député
et la condition nécessaire pour préparer
notre pays au défi qu'il attendent le
gouvernement mobilise des moyens sans
précédent sur la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière et je pourrais
rappeler ici les moyens déployés
notamment dans le cadre de la loop me
la plus grande fermeté s'applique
notamment aux étrangers auteurs d'actes
de délinquance de crimes ou de délits il
Bafou la tradition d'accueil dont la
République sonore leur éloignement et
notre priorité je le rappelle en 2022 ce
sont 2500 titres de séjour qui ont été
retirés pour cause de troubles à l'ordre
public 90 000 refusent des livres de
titres ont été prononcés
3615 étrangers en situation irrégulière
ont été expulsés on retrouve cette même
ambition de fermeté dans le projet porté
par le ministre de l'Intérieur et le
ministre du Travail il entend assouplir
les conditions d'expulsion des étrangers
en levant les protections existantes
cette fermeté n'est pas attendue
seulement par les Français elle est
aussi demandé par les étrangers qui ne
veulent plus être confondus avec ceux
qui abîment leur réputation et mettent à
mal leurs efforts d'intégration et c'est
une fille d'immigrés qui vous le dit
cette fermeté va de pairs avec
l'amélioration de notre politique
d'asile et de nos dispositifs
d'intégration par la maîtrise du
français le travail et le respect de nos
valeurs républicaines pour une politique
d'accueil plus efficace et plus humaine
comme le président de la République nous
l'a demandé nous assumer nous assumons
pleinement aujourd'hui de vouloir
accueillir moins pour accueillir mieux
je vous remercie merci Madame laminet
la parole est à Madame Farida Amrani
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'économie en février vous
annonciez pas de moi de mars rouge il ne
faut pas faire peur aux Français
résultat au mois de mars l'inflation des
prix alimentaires dépassent pour la
première fois les 15% plus que jamais on
n'a jamais ça en fait depuis 1980 et là
la hausse des prix alimentaires affecte
en premier lieu les Français les plus
pauvres dans ma circonscription les
étudiants de l'université d'Evry font la
queue par centaines au resto du coeur
pour se nourrir dans les quartiers
populaires de Corbeil-Essonnes certains
se prive et ne mangent qu'une seule fois
par jour pour garantir un repas le soir
à leurs enfants dans la ville de Lisses
certains retraités sont contraints de
voler au supermarché pour se nourrir
aujourd'hui une famille de deux
personnes dépensent 521 euros par mois
au supermarché c'est quasiment 100 euros
de plus qu'il y a un an plus 25% pour le
riz plus 22% pour le beurre plus 33%
pour les steaks hachés aujourd'hui en
France plus de 8 millions de personnes
ont recours à l'aide alimentaire et ça
c'est votre bilan vous le savez
pertinemment la hausse des prix sur les
dans les supermarchés et dopés par les
profits de l'industrie niveau
alimentaire responsable de 60% de
l'inflation ce trimestre les profits du
secteur ont doublé passant de 3 à 6
milliards mais vous refusez de voir la
réalité en face à la mise en place des
repas de 1 euro pour nos étudiants vous
préférez la mise en place des antivols
sur les sachets de pattes monsieur le
ministre quand allez-vous maîtriser les
marges et profit des multinationales qui
gonfle les prix et alimente la fin en
France quand allez-vous mettre en place
le blocage des prix et l'indexation des
salaires pour éviter les émeutes en
France
je vous remercie mes chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
combe
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Amrani la lutte contre l'inflation et
ses conséquences sur nos concitoyens est
au cœur des préoccupations de ce
gouvernement
en effet nous le savons même si
l'inflation est moins forte en France
qu'ailleurs elle frappe plus durement
les ménages avec les revenus les plus
modestes les personnes âgées mais aussi
ceux qui vivent le plus loin des villes
sur 12 mois l'inflation a atteint
5,6%. c'est heureusement moins
qu'ailleurs en Europe et nous le devons
notamment au 46 milliards d'euros
dépensés par l'État pour contenir la
hausse des prix de l'énergie mais il
était aussi nécessaire d'atténuer les
effets de l'inflation sur les ménages
les plus modestes et c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement agit dès l'été 2022
notamment en augmentant les minima
sociaux de plus de 4% des juillet
dernier complétés au 1er avril d'une
augmentation de 1,6% soit 5,6% sur un an
le montant de l'inflation à cela s'est
ajouté une allocation ex professionnels
de solidarité distribué au ménage les
plus modestes pour un montant de 160
euros en moyenne un chèque énergie
jusqu'à 200 euros par famille pour 11
millions de ménages plus pauvres ou
modeste et puis le renforcement des
moyens des associations de solidarité
avec le triplement des crédits de l'aide
alimentaire passant à 140 millions
d'euros ce qui nous a notamment permis
de débloquer une aide de 10 millions
d'euros en urgence cet automne pour
aider dans l'urgence les étudiants sur
le volet alimentaire on continue bien
sûr à aider les plus fragiles et les
classes modestes ma collègue Olivia
Grégoire tout à l'heure a fait référence
au trimestre anti-inflation et puis je
signale également le programme mieux
manger pour tous dont le déploiement est
en cours c'est 60 millions d'euros qui
seront dévolus aux associations d'aide
humanitaires au niveau national mais
aussi sur les territoires pour permettre
un accès à une alimentation saine et de
qualité pour les familles modestes et
moyennes dans notre pays je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre madame
Amrani merci pâte plus steak haché plus
2,46 € en un an les chiffres ne montent
pas monsieur le ministre le ticket de
caisse est là entre mes mains si vous le
voulez je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Laurence Edel
Grillère pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire
monsieur le ministre après vous avoir
sollicité pour sauver la production de
cerises pour développer celle de la
châtaigne aujourd'hui je reviens vers
vous concernant une autre spécialité
française cette spécialité qui fait le
bonheur de nos voisins européens et
d'autres pays dans le monde nous a
amenés à perdre notre souveraineté
alimentaire au profit de l'importation
nombreux produits comme la moitié des
fruits que nous consommons je veux
évidemment parler de la spécialité
française de surtransposition de normes
agricoles ce 26 octobre 2022 nous avons
eu un nouvel exemple de l'ingéniosité de
notre pays en la matière lancès a décidé
d'interdir à partir du 25 avril
l'utilisation d'un insecticide utilisé
pour l'export des céréales dans une
dizaine de jours les agriculteurs
français ne pourront plus exporter des
céréales hors de l'Union Européenne ces
exportations représentent de l'ordre de
11,5 millions de tonnes de grains
d'hiver 3 soit 3,8 milliards d'euros une
paille et ce pas le pire car dans le
même temps nous pourrons nous Français
continuer à importer des céréales
traitées avec cette insecticide cette
situation interroge elle pourrait même
prêter un sourire si elle n'avait pas
autant de conséquences pour nos
agriculteurs pour les habitants des pays
importateurs de céréales pour les
équilibres géopolitiques que l'on cesse
ne se pose pas la question de
l'existence d'un Pass sanitaire de
l'émergence de solutions de la pérennité
de nos exploitations c'est une chose car
son métier d'évaluer le risque pour la
santé mais où est la place du politique
pour définir le niveau de danger
acceptable nous ne pouvons laisser faire
nous ne pouvons être aussi inactif que
les gouvernements de droite et de gauche
qui ont des industrialisé la France et
laisser mourir notre agriculture loi
égalim retraite agricole assurance
récolte nos ambitions pour la
souveraineté alimentaire pour nos
agriculteurs sont claires depuis six ans
alors Monsieur le Ministre ma question
est la suivante comment comptez-vous
concilier l'atteinte de l'objectif de
souverain commentaires avec les
objectifs environnementaux et de santé
publique les surtout aussi sur
transposition française sont-elles une
fatalité ou allons-nous nous donner les
moyens merci beaucoup ma chère collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Marc feno
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députés merci de votre
question qui me permettra de compléter
la première réponse que j'ai pu faire
sur ce sujet de la fausse fine et
globalement sur ces sujets de produits
phytosanitaires et j'aurais une autre
question je crois tout à l'heure sur ce
même sujet d'abord rappeler je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure que sur ce sujet là c'est
bon de lire le droit et de dire le droit
alors je vais lire le droit sur la
question de la faucine puisque ça
procède d'un texte une dérogation qui
dit les choses suivantes les limites
maximales à l'applicable au résidus des
pesticides établies conformément
présents règlement ne s'applique pas ne
s'applique pas
aux produits couvrant l'annexion destiné
à l'exportation vers des pays tiers
lorsqu'il a été prouvé que le pays tiers
de destination exige ou accepte un
traitement particulier afin de prévenir
l'introduction d'organismes nuisibles
sur son territoire nous sommes
strictement dans cette disposition là
qui est le deuxième paragraphe du
règlement 369 2005 je le dis parce que
il faut d'abord agir en droit sur ces
affaires là et donc on a besoin d'agir
en droit et de rappeler ce qui est le
droit européen qui permet cette
dérogation et c'est donc pour chaque
avant-droit on va on va produire cette
dérogation et je ne redis pas ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur la volonté
que nous avons de contribuer à
l'exportation le deuxième sujet qu'il y
a c'est que le droit européen est en
clair nous avons besoin aussi de
conforter les besoins que sont ceux de
nos pays d'export et je pense en
particulier au pays il arrive Sud
Méditerranée et je voudrais rappeler
quand même que nous sommes dans une
situation particulière qui exige aussi
au-delà du juridique de penser
géopolitique et de pensées politiques
qui exigent aussi que nous assurions la
sécurité alimentaire de nos voisins
c'est la responsabilité de la France et
la vocation de la France et c'est la
nécessité que nous avons dans le moment
particulier de la guerre en Ukraine de
faire en sorte que non seulement nous
couvrions les besoins de nos voisins que
ce soit pas d'autres y compris parfois
ceux qui mènent guère sur le continent
européen qui viennent le couvrir parce
que nous nous serions abstenus de cette
volonté là d'exploitation et donc nous
allons nous conformer aux droits à la
politique et à la géopolitique et c'est
peut-être ce que vous appelez de vos
vœux mais en tout cas vous nous
trouverez au nom du gouvernement nous
sommes tous à partager cette volonté là
pour faire en sorte que nous retrouvions
notre rang merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Dominique Pottier
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente ma question qui va
détonner avec les trois précédentes sur
lances s'adresse à même la première
ministre au vu du caractère
interministériel de la question les
dernières déclarations du gouvernement
sur le S métolaclore pour le moins paru
confuse au moment où notre pays a besoin
de se rassembler dans la clarté alors je
vais essayer à travers ma question de
donner l'occasion de faire la clarté en
droit comme dit le ministre de
l'Agriculture à l'instant d'abord
rappeler le caractère anachronique de la
remise en cause de la décision de lances
et l'objet et le simplement la réponse à
une saisine des ministère de
l'agriculture mais également de la santé
et de l'environnement le 17 mai 2021
l'EVA s'apprête l'agence européenne à
rendre des conclusions équivalentes et
puis enfin nous le savons des
alternatives existantes
sur le fond il me semble que c'est en
fait une remise en cause une remise en
cause de l'article 13 13-1 de la loi
promulgué en 2015 et qui donne à lances
les pouvoirs de déterminer quand un
produit autorisé ou qui ne l'est pas
toute reprise en main politique serait
une fiction elle reviendrait de fait à
donner le plein pouvoir à l'économie
dans une vision paradoxale où les
bénéfices seraient pour quelques-uns et
les risques pour tous les autres nous
aimerions madame la Première ministre
que vous puissiez nous rassurer sur ce
point nous sommes prêts à vous engager
sur tout le plan écofito 2030 il reprend
en grande partie et préconisations qui
avait été enterré en 2014 dans le
rapport que j'avais rendu à votre
prédécesseur mais répondez nous sur une
question très précise oui aux
transitions oui au synchronisation
Europe France mais de grâce ne touchez
pas à l'article 13 13 1 il est la
garantie le contrat de confiance entre
notre pays et l'agriculture il est très
clairement la garantie de la santé des
sols de la terre et de la santé des
hommes les socialistes sont extrêmement
attachés aux institutions républicaines
et scientifique en matière de sécurité
nucléaire comment matière de sécurité
sanitaire garantissez-nous que vous ne
remettrez pas en cause nos institutions
que vous renforcerez leur autorité au
nom de l'intérêt général
je vous remercie la parole est Monsieur
Marc phénom ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député potier
en vous entendant je me disais que je
pense que vous n'avez pas eu la même
lecture que ce que de ce que j'ai dit
que la vérité de ce que j'ai dit sur ce
sujet en particulier du S métola clore
c'est là dessus que vous réagissez la
seule chose que j'ai pu dire et exprimer
je continue à l'exprimer c'est la
nécessité vous l'avez dit vous-même de
synchroniser nos décisions nationales
avec les sa décision européennes ça ne
me paraît pas une une injonction
contradictoire avec la volonté que nous
partageons de procéder à une réduction
de l'utilisation des produits finaux
sanitaires en France mais si nous sommes
comme nous sommes dans le même marché
commun dans le même marché unique si
nous procédons à des décisions qui sont
complètement désynchronisées les autres
il arrivera la chose qui est déjà arrivé
sur d'autres produits c'est que nous
perdrons en compétitivité nous perdrons
en souveraineté et nos voisins européens
se feront fort parce qu'ils sont chauds
aussi compétitifs que nous de nous
fournir c'est ça la question qui est
devant nous et nous avons besoin de
changer de méthode je répète que nous
avons besoin de changer de méthode c'est
à dire de faire en sorte que tout le
monde se sente
appliquer dans la nécessité de la
réduction des produits fasses
phytosanitaires de la santé et de
l'environnement mais que parallèlement
tout le monde se sente impliqué dans la
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
et de la capacité à ce que notre ferme
France reste productive sinon si on a
passé deux pendant et ces deux éléments
ça ne marchera pas donc la volonté
qu'elle a un autre elle n'est pas
différente de cela il n'est pas question
de remettre en cause ou quoi que ce soit
il est question de remettre en cause une
méthode tout le monde est comptable de
la souveraineté comme tout le monde est
comptable de l'environnement et de la
santé de tout le monde c'est ça la
vérité c'est ça sur lequel nous avons
besoin de travailler et donc la méthode
qui a été définie avec madame la
Première ministre c'est une méthode
simple c'est de regarder produit pour
produit molécules par molécule filière
par filière où sont les impasses où sont
les alternatives on a besoin d'accélérer
sur les alternatives monsieur vous dites
on a des solutions les mêmes qui ont dit
qu'il y avait des solutions sur la
betterave et on n'a pas les solutions
les mêmes qui ont dit qu'on avait les
solutions sur les cerises et on a perdu
sur les cerises de la compétitivité et
donc moi les solutions je veux les voir
permettez-moi de le dire et donc on a
besoin de les mettre sur la table pour
pouvoir sortir avec plus de facilité et
donc l'été n'est pas de sortir du
dispositif légal mais d'avancer pour la
méthode et sur une méthode qui change
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Jocelyn de
signer pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
territoriale monsieur Béchu monsieur le
ministre lors de la commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur les raisons de la
perte d'indépendance et de souveraineté
énergétique conformément aux attentes
des Français nous avions proposé avec
pertinence différentes mesures dont un
moratoire et l'annulation de tous les
projets en cours
avec plus de 500 éoliennes mon
département de l'Aisne a largement
contribué à les formations
écologique face à l'inaction du
président de la région des
Hauts-de-France Xavier Bertrand le 2
avril dernier 17 mai courageux ont pris
la décision de mener simultanément une
consultation locale au sujet d'un énième
projet de construction d'éoliennes
géante de 180 mètres de haut malgré les
pressions exercées par vos préfets vos
sous-préfets le vote a eu lieu et le nom
l'a emporté à plus de
87,5%. vous le dites illégal mais avec
plus de 43% de participation il est plus
légitime qu'un grand nombre de députés
ici présents vous-même avez été élu
maire avec un taux de participation de
seulement 34,25% des inscrits ce qui
vous rend également moins légitime que
ce scrutin aujourd'hui les actionnaires
attendent des pouvoirs publics qu'il
respectent leur volonté alors monsieur
le ministre je vous le vous engagez-vous
à ce coquin projet éolien ne voit le
jour sur le territoire de ces 17
communes
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
Josselin de Signy
vous évoquez de sujets celui d'abord de
ce référendum local ou de cette
consultation locale je suis pas en train
d'en remettre en cause la légitimité je
pense qu'il serait dangereux de
considérer que le taux de participation
entraîne d'ailleurs un niveau de
reconnaissance ou de légitimité
particulière de ce qui siègent dans une
enceinte quelle qu'elle soit
mais je ne le prends pas comme étant une
critique mais plutôt que une manière par
anticipation de répondre à des critiques
qui seraient posées le fond de votre
question c'est bien sur le nombre et le
niveau de parc éolien qui peuvent être
présents sur tel ou tel partie du
territoire
j'excuse Agnès dont vous savez que c'est
la responsabilité qu'a portée cette loi
qui a été l'occasion de très nombreux
débats ici d'accélération sur les
énergies renouvelables avec une grande
ambition du département du gouvernement
faire en sorte que nous soyons la
première nation à sortir des énergies
fossiles et pour ça il faut de la
sobriété il faut de l'efficacité il faut
du nucléaire et il faut des énergies
renouvelables dans cela nous avons
concentré nos efforts d'accélération sur
l'éolien offshore et sur le
photovoltaïque et dans les débats une
partie de ceux qui disent attention à ce
que l'éolien terrestre ne se traduisent
pas par des crispations supplémentaires
sur le terrain ils ont été entendus
d'abord les zones d'accélération sont
soumises à un avis conforme des communes
la possibilité de faire en sorte d'avoir
des zones
d'exclusion ou de limitation à la main
des collectivités locales a fait l'objet
d'un accord entre Assemblée nationale et
Sénat et enfin le concept la notion
juridique de saturation visuelle que
vous évoquez en filigrane dans votre
question elle a été consacrée par la loi
et elle devient un des éléments
d'appréciation de l'autorité
environnementale de là où je suis je ne
connais pas dans le détail le projet
dont vous parlez mais je sais ce qu'est
l'état du droit et la manière dont sur
tous ces points nous avons fait en sorte
d'essayer de refaire de la concertation
ascendante en partant du terrain et
d'ailleurs pour une raison d'efficacité
c'est que quand les riverains sont
contre à la fin les projets ne sortent
pas merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député
allez-y ministre devant
l'incompréhension d'un tel refus un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens
pourraient être suspicieux afin de lever
tout doute sur le fonctionnement de
l'éolien en France et par volonté de
transparence au nom du groupe
rassemblement national je demande à ce
qu'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur le financement de
l'éolien soit mis en place dans les six
mois à venir je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Vincent Thiébaut pour le groupe
horizon
merci madame la Présidente cette
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
délégué chargé des collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre la réussite la
plupart de nos politiques publiques vont
passer par les collectivités
territoriales et c'est un sujet
d'aménagement de territoires et cela
particulièrement dans la réussite dans
l'enjeu majeur qui est la transition
écologique toutefois cela ne pourra pas
se faire sans imaginaire soutenue dans
les territoires qui apporte qui
accompagne les porteurs de projets mais
surtout les élus locaux
la Fédération des pays et des pôles
d'équilibre territoriaux et ruraux dont
je salue notre collègue Josiane cordelu
réaffirmé récemment dans une tribune
cette ingénierie du développement local
et des transitions et elle a fait
l'objet d'une signature de 12000 élus
locaux cette tribune site par un
générique du développement local et des
transitions est entendu une ingénierie
d'accompagnement des porteurs de projets
locaux qui par leur Expertis ça va
articuler des outils réglementaires au
disposition contre-attuelle comme le
contrat de relance de transition
écologique où les fonds européens à une
échelle supra communautaire c'est une
ingénierie financière et d'animation de
la fonction publique territoriale nos
élus spécifiquement ruraux évoquent
régulièrement leur désarroi quand on
leur manque d'ingénierie à cet effet il
est préconisé le 1% ingénierie à savoir
le financement ne s'agénierie par
mobilisation d'un profond de volume
financiers la première ministre est
énoncée à évoquer lors du congrès des
maires le 24 novembre dernier notamment
un fond dédié un générique de 200
millions d'euros ma première question
est que pensez-vous de cette proposition
de 1% ingénierie et ma seconde question
sera de connaître à la traduction
opérationnelle du fond de soutien évoqué
par le Premier ministre lors du congrès
des mers je vous remercie pour vos
réponses merci Mélanie merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Dominique Faure ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Thiébaut la question de
l'ingénierie territoriale
tu es beau
monsieur le député je vous ai perdu vous
êtes assis merci
la question de la généri territoriale
est essentielle pour soutenir
l'aménagement et le développement
durable de nos territoires afin
d'accompagner les collectivités
territoriales le gouvernement a dégagé
des moyens inédits au cours des
dernières années via la NCT à l'image
des 900 chefs de projets et des
programmes d'ingénierie que vous
connaissez bien tels que petite ville de
demain ou action cœur de ville
s'agissant du 1% ingénierie que vous
évoquez c'est une proposition comme vous
l'avez indiqué qui portait par plusieurs
associations des luttes dont
l'Association nationale des pols
territoriaux et des pays la NPP nous
avons lu effectivement très
attentivement leur tribune c'est une
proposition qui également a été formulée
par les sénateurs Charles Guénet et
Céline Brulin que j'ai reçu le 8 février
dernier à l'occasion de la remise de
leur rapport sur la NCT cette
proposition consisterait en un Front
national pas répondre les collectivités
elle nécessite une étude approfondie
pour pouvoir imaginer les scénarios
crédibles mais c'est 1% ont vraiment du
sens qu'ils soient en ingénierie
prospective en ingénierie financière en
ingénierie technique mais serait-il
dédié à l'ingénierie de projet pour
lequel les crédits d'investissement
étaient prévus peuvent-ils être
mutualisés entre plusieurs collectivités
à quel niveau en fait c'est l'objet de
cette étude qui va explorer les
modalités précises d'un tel dispositif
dans l'attente de ces résultats je vous
rappelle que différents dispositifs
visent d'ores et déjà renforcer
l'ingénierie dans le cadre de toutes les
transitions territoriales que nous
sommes amenés à traverser et le fond
vert en est un exemple frappant donc sur
la question de l'ingénierie en milieu
rural cible de cette proposition le
gouvernement lancera dans les prochaines
semaines un programme France ruralité
qui inclura toute l'ingénierie que vous
vous le souhaitez merci Madame la
Ministre allez-y mon cher collègue
je voulais juste vous arrêter quand même
c'est surtout les territoires souvent
les derniers élèves qui rendaient en
pâtissent le plus nous sommes en
générique on souhaite très sensible à ce
sujet merci pour votre réponse merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Giovanni Williams pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le garde des sceaux
le dernier rapport de Madame la
Défenseur des droits confirme ce que
nous avons tous déjà porte le triste
constat de décision de justice
inexécutée affectant d'une part nos
compatriotes juste ici et d'autre part
l'autorité des magistrats cet ensemble
participez l'as au non respect du droit
et à la justice et de la justice notre
actualité locale à la Martinique et en
Guadeloupe porte un triste exemple de
ces dysfonctionnements en effet vous
avez reçu Monsieur le Ministre et à
l'initiative de mon collègue
Jean-Philippe Milan une lettre ouverte
des parlementaires de Martinique et de
Guadeloupe le 6 avril dernier portant
sur la situation de Monsieur Noël Defour
juste iciable placé en détention
provisoire au centre pénitentiaire de
Ducos en Martinique bien que le juge
d'instruction est autorisé par
ordonnance monsieur dofour à se rendre
au chevet de sa fille de 3 ans
hospitalisé gravement malade il s'avère
qu'il n'a pu s'y rendre qu'une seule
fois et quelques heures dans des délais
anormalement longs je sais que votre
cabinet a répondu à mon collègue sur
l'interprétation de cette ordonnance
néanmoins il y a lieu de relever des
difficultés liées à l'application des
décisions judiciaires urgentes je ne
suis pas ici pour en faire un procès
politique mais pour vous signaler les
dysfonctionnements structurels des
services dont vous avez la charge
sachant qu'il s'agit d'un sujet qui
concerne également le ministère de
l'Intérieur puisque notre particularité
résulte du fait que ces services de
transfèrement et d'escorte sont assurés
à la fois par l'argenterie et la police
nationale les syndicats pénitentiaires
ont exprimé leur souhait d'assurer ces
missions pour plus d'efficacité avec les
moyens qui s'imposent et par cette
occasion monsieur le ministre je vous
rappelle que nous parlementaires
ultramarin avant saisi votre cabinet
pour travailler sur la question de la
justice dans nos territoires nous avons
des propositions concrètes à vous faire
donc monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous assurer que vous recevrez les
parlementaires ultramarins pour traiter
en profondeur ces problématiques
la parole est à me tuer Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
William
bienvenue Bienvenue à la Chancellerie
quand vous le souhaitez pour évoquer les
propositions que vous avez à me faire
maintenant s'agissant de la situation
particulière de Monsieur dofour monsieur
Defour vous l'avez rappelé et détenu il
a par
l'intermédiaire de ses avocats
demandaient au juge d'instructions
l'autorisation de se rendre au chevet de
sa petite fille âgée de trois ans et
demi et atteinte d'une pathologie que
l'on peut qualifier de très lourde très
vite dans les heures qui ont suivi la
saisine le juge d'instruction a répondu
positivement
c'est une autorisation dit le juge
d'instruction exceptionnelle et le
détenu devait réintégrer l'établissement
pénitentiaire après la visite il y a une
difficulté d'exécution dès le lendemain
il y a une nouvelle saisine le juge
d'instruction dans les heures qui ont
suivi là encore a rendu une nouvelle
ordonnance le préfet la justice le
ministère de l'Intérieur le ministère de
la Justice ont fait en sorte que très
vite cet homme puisse voir sa petite
fille si de nouvelles autorisations
doivent intervenir elles ne se feront
pas sur une auto-césine du magistrat
instructeur mais sur une nouvelle
demande des avocats de ce monsieur qui
est mis en examen vous rappeler dans la
lettre qu'il est présumé innocence est
une c'est un rappel si j'ose dire
superfétatoire je veux également dire
que en ce qui concerne l'Outre-mer nous
avons augmenté le nombre de personnels
pénitentiaires et nous avons
spécifiquement créé pour Cayenne et pour
Mayotte des brigades de l'urgence pour
que des magistrats et des greffiers
puissent être embauchés très rapidement
puisse partir durant 6 mois 6 mois et un
jour très précisément pour prêter main
forte au magistrats sur place pour le
reste je serai tout à fait ravi de vous
recevoir et d'analyser monsieur le
député les différentes propositions que
vous me ferez
j'aime beaucoup Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à monsieur Sylvain carrière
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
l'heure est grave la sécheresse record
de l'été dernier c'est 33 jours de vague
de chaleur et plus de 66000 hectares
d'espace naturel partie en fumée cette
année après 32 jours sans pluie on
compte déjà 20 000 hectares de brûler je
veux ici rendre hommage aux 200 pompiers
mobilisés ces derniers jours dans
l'Hérault pour lutter contre le feu
mais vous en bon pompier pyromane vous
ne faites rien pour prévenir et contrer
ces incendies malgré les alertes
incessantes du GIEC de Météo France le
cycle de l'eau est perturbé et en grand
péril avait lui ce sont tous les
écosystèmes l'agriculture mais aussi la
consommation humaine qui sont menacées
en 2019 vous annoncez une baisse de 10%
des prélèvements à l'horizon 2025 mais
rien n'a changé rien n'est planifié vous
réitérez ces fausses promesses pour 2027
les effets d'annonce vous ne connaissez
que ça incapable de planifier les usages
de l'eau vous êtes à la botte des
industriels qui à l'image du capitalisme
s'accaparent toutes les richesses même
quand il s'agit de bien commun
l'ONU annoncé en 2021 que la sécheresse
est sur le point de devenir la prochaine
pandémie et qui n'existe aucun vaccin
pour la guérir mais pour vous le nous
sommes en guerre n'est pas contre la
sécheresse vous êtes en guerre contre le
discours de la raison qui appelle
rationaliser les usages et garantir
l'accès à l'eau potable vous êtes en
guerre contre les Mahorais ces Français
qui sont 30% à ne pas être raccordés à
l'occurrence pour lequel la crise
alimentaire guette
vous êtes en guerre pour l'agro
industrie en croisade seuls et contre
tous sur un sujet qui vous dépasse à
l'heure où la réponse doit et ne sera
que collective alors qu'attendez-vous
pour décréter l'état d'urgence sanitaire
à Mayotte qu'attendez-vous pour occuper
pour vous occuper des 500 000 Français
qui n'ont pas d'eau chez eux en
définitive qu'attendez-vous pour
planifier je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe bechut ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
carrière ne pas connaître un sujet est
un avantage dont il ne faut pas abuser
et
sincèrement enchaîner autant de
contre-vérités en si peu de temps c'est
une insulte je comprends que ça fasse
réagir vos collègues mais j'ai peur qu'à
travers de leur réactions eux-mêmes
refusent d'avoir la vérité des chiffres
d'après l'ONF vous croyez à l'ONF
l'Office National des Forêts qui fait
son bulletin au 31 mars c'est 1635
hectares qui ont été brûlés depuis le
premier janvier pas 20.000 donc si déjà
dans la précision des chiffres vous avez
un écart de 1 à 10 on a un petit sujet
ensuite vous entendrez expliquer qu'on
ne n'a pas de stratégie alors que nous
avons réuni le premier conseil
d'anticipation contre la sécheresse des
23 février que nous avons lancé avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'eau pas à
partir de la vérité qu'aurait le
gouvernement à partir des agences des
comités de bassin de ceux qui sont sur
le terrain vous êtes dans l'incantation
vous répétez des éléments de langage
alors qu'ils sont décorés de la réalité
vous faites comme si il suffisait de
claquer des doigts pour régler les
problèmes peut-être qu'avec un peu de
danse de la pluie Jean-Luc Mélenchon on
aurait de la pluie partout sur les
territoires mais vous êtes dans
l'incantation regardez la réalité en
face regardez les trajectoires que nous
avons fait regardez le travail qui a
lieu sur le terrain si
[Applaudissements]
si le niveau de décibel de Madame panot
faisait preuve faisait pleuvoir on aura
des problèmes d'inondation dans
l'hémicycle et pas des problèmes de
sécheresse continuez sur ce registre ça
ne résout rien écouté ce qui travaille
écoutez ce qui précisément au niveau des
comités de bassin les élus locaux
regardez le plan que nous avons en
outre-mer avec Mayotte sur tous ces
sujets il y a une réalité objective que
vous refusez de voir en face pour les
questions idéologiques et c'est désolant
vraiment polémiquer surtout c'est
désolant
c'est beaucoup Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Daniel la baronne
pour le groupe Renaissance
ma question s'adresse à Gabriel Attal
ministre des contes publics depuis la
loi du 23 octobre 2018 portant sur la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale sociale
et douanière le gouvernement a engagé
une action forte contre toutes les
formes de fraude grâce à l'augmentation
des capacités d'enquêtes à disposition
de l'autorité judiciaire avec la
création des services d'enquête
judiciaires des finances l'adoption de
mesure de publicité en cas de fraude
fiscale grave la possibilité de
poursuivre les intermédiaires la
révision du mode de calcul des amendes
pénales en cas de fraude fiscale sans
compter la suppression du verrou de
Bercy l'action du gouvernement a été
volontaire et résolu un succès
puisqu'elle a rapporté 14,6 milliards
d'euros en 2022 1,2 milliards de plus
qu'en 2021 et presque deux fois plus
qu'en 2020 en dépit de ce succès évident
on sait que la lutte contre la fraude
est un combat permanent de nouveaux
mécanismes frauduleux apparaissent sur
la TVA par exemple avec la numérisation
de l'économie ministre des douanes vous
avez engagé avec le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire une réflexion
visant à définir une stratégie
d'ensemble de l'action des douanes
françaises et à consolider nos
instruments de lutte contre la fraude
douanière le contournement de droit à
l'importation la contrefaçon
l'utilisation des actifs numériques le
trafic de tabac capter l'argent sali par
ses infractions doit constituer un
objectif prioritaire il ne peut y avoir
d'unité de la nation française sans la
présence visible et efficace de cet état
régalien que les douanes incarnent
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
rappeler les chiffres exceptionnels qui
caractérisent l'efficacité de l'activité
des douanes et nous indiquer les
orientations que vous entendez suivre
dans le cadre d'un projet de loi qui
pourrait être dédié spécifiquement aux
douanes je vous remercie merci beaucoup
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
la baronne je veux d'abord vous
remercier Monsieur le Député de mettre
en avant et en valeur des agents dont on
parle finalement assez peu on a souvent
l'occasion ici dans cette hémicycle de
mettre en lumière le travail remarquable
effectué par les policiers par les
gendarmes plus rarement par nos
douaniers qui réalisent un travail
absolument exceptionnel dans notre pays
pour protéger la frontière pour
contrôler les marchandises et c'est un
très grand honneur pour moi d'être le
ministre des douaniers de notre pays
c'est un honneur et c'est aussi une
responsabilité celle de leur donner les
moyens d'agir efficacement ils le font
déjà j'ai annoncé il y a quelques
semaines avec Gérald Darmanin les
chiffres liés au trafic de stupéfiants
en 2022 les douaniers ont réalisé plus
de 70% des saisies de stupéfiants dans
notre pays j'ai fixé une très grande
priorité vous le savez c'est la lutte
contre le trafic et contre la
contrebande de tabac et de cigarettes
dans notre pays vous me demandiez des
chiffres il y a un chiffre
particulièrement modifiant en 2022 640
tonnes de tabac de contrebande saisie
c'était 400 tonnes en 2021 on voit une
explosion c'est évidemment lié à
l'efficacité grandissante de nos
services c'est aussi lié évidemment à
des trafics qui augmentent or le trafic
de tabac dans notre pays c'est une plaie
pour la sécurité puisque sa finance des
réseaux criminels qui mettent en péril
la sécurité des Français c'est une plaie
pour la santé puisque c'est évidemment
mauvais de fumer et en plus de la
cigarette de contrefaçon c'est encore
pire c'est une plaie pour le réseau des
buralistes dont nous avons besoin
partout sur le territoire pour créer du
lien social et de l'accès aux services
publics et c'est une plaie évidemment
pour les finances publiques les trafics
augmentent nous avons démantelés l'an
dernier ça n'était jamais arrivé dans
notre pays 5 usines de contrefaçons de
tabac sur le sol national qui pouvait
produire entre 1 et 2 millions de
cigarettes par jour et donc j'ai annoncé
un plan majeur qui s'inscrira vous
l'avez dit dans le projet de loi que je
présenterai jeudi je dis je présenterai
en conseil des ministres le premier
projet de loi dédié à depuis 60 ans le
coeur de ce projet de loi c'est
évidemment l'encadrement du droit de
visite douanier qui nous a été demandé
par le Conseil constitutionnel nous
avons beaucoup travaillé avec Eric
Dupont-Moretti je crois que nous avons
trouvé le bon équilibre entre les
libertés publiques et l'efficacité
nécessaire de nos services douaniers
mais nous allons aller plus loin pour
moderniser et renforcer l'activité et
l'action de nos douaniers avec des
moyens supplémentaires pour détecter les
convois qui arrivent sur notre
territoire avec des stupéfiants ou avec
du tabac avec des moyens supplémentaires
pour réguler ce qui se passe en ligne et
notamment la contrefaçon avec la
création d'une réserve opérationnelle
des douanes il en existe pour la police
pour les gendarmes pas pour les
douaniers vous le voyez nous avons un
plan majeur de renforcement de l'action
de nos douaniers et nous pouvons être
fiers chacune et chacun ici de l'action
remarquable qui est la leur partout sur
notre territoire merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre la séance est suspendue